welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
thank you I think they do do it for the
men but it's like sexual tension it's
not relationship attention so you can
kind of do a cheat code you can go get a
BBL get a nice body and you do get more
attention from them than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though if it goes
so deeper though because I know what
you're talking about and she has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest end
it's full women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's picky or men or women
men women are more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them men do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard and they're more rigid
than women I think men are pickier than
women 100 certainly but they will not
marry they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last oh I I done an only fan but it
wasn't like vagina boobs it was lingerie
yeah builds right whatever I'd done it
and when I finished it I felt very
degraded I felt very like why did I
actually do that now I know there's
girls out there who do that they don't
feel that way that is perfectly fine you
do you you feel the way you feel but me
personally like like in the future how
like when I have kids not in the future
and if my kids found out about that
they'll probably get bullied in school
there are people like oh your mom doing
this your mom doing that and your man as
well he's not coming if you don't
respect yourself and you're selling your
body online like I can't speak for
everyone I can just speak for myself if
you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not a high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and as you guys
already know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you don't don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show um the first is that we have
four membership tiers guys the only one
you care about is the fourth tier that's
the that is a one-on-one call with me
once a month
um how do you get a million subscribers
in a year I'll tell you sign up for that
call also guys the second tier if you
want to see me freestyle rap sign up for
the second tier for the behind the
scenes Vlogs also guys um follow my
Instagram that took away my first one
just pearly things one also I'm back on
um Tick Tock they took away my first
second third fourth and fifth Tick Tock
so I'm on my sixth just pearly things
um also guys subscribe to wife school
and
um King how many likes do we need to
open up the chat today
one five so one thousand five hundred
likes and we will open up the chat
um I think that's all the announcements
we have
yeah I think that's it okay oh and
subscribe to my two um the two other
talents we have at the just pearly
things Network I'm Auntie Jenny and King
Richie's so welcome to the show
everybody
um to start we are gonna do your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here go
around and then we'll do the second row
okay hey guys I'm Kyra I'm 22. I'm
single and a fun fact I'm gonna say I
have never been in a relationship before
yeah that's my fun fact
uh my name is Rudy but everybody calls
me real I am 20.
it's a bit complicated and a fun fact
about me what's complicated about it can
I be in on the no no how much time do
you actually have no okay so so is this
like you guys are you guys are hooking
up
we've known each other for a while and
it's just in that difficult stage but
you know so you've been going on dates
and stuff or you've known them for years
and he's getting out the friend zone no
we've been through all of that we've had
the waves but you know things happen
things got skewed with but we're just
what what happened let me in let me in I
just I want to be in the now
um
like three minutes in no I moved here
Manchester uh to study so it was that
distance that kind of long distance
thing you know messages got skew where
things got changed and do you know what
I mean that kind of vibe so it's
complicated but a fun fact about me I am
actually double jointed in this thumb if
you can see on the camera it kind of
bends like this so like I'll try that at
home if you can't do it I'll teach you
how to do it but yeah that's a fun fact
please don't teach me
oh God I'm Amira and I'm 21.
um I'm single
um and a fun fact about me is I want to
learn how to do that I want to know what
I really thought dude outside yeah I
can't do that
oh go ahead
um I'm Cecilia I'm 21 as well about to
be 22 I'm single and fun fact about me
um I'm South American
we have a young Couch today but
everyone's under what 23 on the couch
yeah yeah okay
um
Justin do you want to go sure my name is
justin37 wouldn't you like to know and
no fun facts for now so oh
I'm Troy 47 single and I once went out
to party in London and I woke up two
days later in Vegas
wow can I what what's what prompted did
you figure out what prompted you to get
from London to Vegas
um I think it was just excessive alcohol
and the bun homie of the spirit of the
occasion uh it was pretty wild though I
woke up and I was like where the hell am
I and um turned out to be Vegas so yeah
it was a good night
um go ahead hi my name is Regina I'm 28.
I'm single and the fun fact about me
it's um I don't know keep keep watching
okay
that's how I flooded in my fun fact evil
but my name is Iman
um I'm 21 and I'm single and a fun fact
about me is
um
I can juggle oranges
that is fun yeah it's a good party trick
yeah yeah how many can you juggle I'm
three three yeah that's it I can't give
you four
okay yeah so you got some room for
improvement you can get to maybe six
someday or yeah maybe yeah or like other
objects okay
hey guys I'm Alex I am 28 from fact
about me is I'm an avid salsa and
bachata kizomba dancer oh that's cool
okay so today's topic
is modern women should stay if high
value men cheat
so there was a certain footballer that
is in the news
and he's in the news because his wife
divorced him for cheating however
all of the money was in his mom's his
mom's name
so in hindsight being 20 20
knowing that he was taking fully 100
taking care of her
should she have stayed
why don't we start with the couch
um and then we'll get we'll get the
women's opinions and then we'll get the
men's so start here
I don't know I think I think it's all
about the principal
I get that it's like 2023
I get the I don't know where we're
moving towards more liberal times you've
got to do what you've got to do but I
just feel like
oh I just if it was me I wouldn't want
to know things like that I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to know that it was coming
I don't know I feel like I need a yes or
no I need a yes or no are you are you
team stay or team go
I think go go yeah it's not very Mandy
and I go it's that manly to cheat
I guess
you don't think it's manly to sleep with
multiple women
it's like a masculine treat
I guess so I you know what the more I
hear it the more I feel like you know
what I'm gonna have to accept that if I
want a high value man if yeah if I want
a man they're gonna exercise their
options how do I feel about that I don't
know but it I guess it seems like
the reality that we live in
so I I don't know it's hard do you think
she should date a footballer and expect
him to be faithful is that a good bet
do you know what you know what I think
this might be my idea of a high value
man I don't know about everyone else's
opinion but my idea of a hide value man
is that you have to be so certain in
yourself and closed off because I don't
consider high value if everybody else
can have you yeah because why would you
want something that everybody else can
have that's not special do you know what
I mean do you see what I mean so then
why do women keep sleeping with them
if women in general knows them knowing
that he's a cheater a Serial cheater do
you think women sleep with Drake and are
worried about his monogamy you think
Drake has a shortage of women no
absolutely not I don't I think he's got
a whole real of girls that he could just
call up and be like yo you're trying to
slide or what you know what I mean so
would you say in general high-value men
do tend to cheat and women don't care
I think it comes down to the type of guy
that person is if you're that guy saying
yeah I've had I'm high valued I'm high
valued are you though are you yes
usually if they're rich enough and
famous enough and successful or not yeah
that's when you decide is high value
meaning your success what you can
provide who you can protect what you can
do for your family what car you drive
what house you live in or is hide valued
the way you're raised the work the
morals your mum brought you up in I
would say it's the men that are the men
that women pick
it's the market it's demanding Supply
isn't it you know you've got to look at
what what is the market demand if
everybody if all these women want to
sleep with Drake then regardless of what
we may think of that that demand would
indicate that Drake is high value
I'm a sex worker
so that means I get paid to have men
that cheat on their wives or oh wow or
their girlfriends and I get them every
single day
most of the time like they do it with a
sex worker because they feel like
there's no there's no strings attached
to it and uh
there a lot most of the time like I
don't even see like the WhatsApp picture
on the on their number because they have
a wife and kids
but then when they come to you and then
they feel like too like um comfortable
enough they're gonna tell you even like
the story of their life
and most of the time like there's like a
very lonely man inside of a marriage hmm
I'm not saying like cheating it's a good
thing because it's not I've been in a
relationship and I've been cheated as
well even though I'm a sex worker and
even like my my job has been used
against me
from my exes like I was like oh yeah you
shouldn't be caring because you're a sex
worker
so that's why I'm cheating oh that's why
I'm having like a free time around I
think that's unfair
um I mean it's unfairs from my point of
view yes because as I said as I said
it's my job and like if I go into a
relationship to get to know someone here
I always like a disclaimer I'm this this
is me so you let them know up front yeah
always
but you're still having sex at work
yeah but like that's my job yeah but it
doesn't take away that you're sleeping
with other people yeah but I get paid no
so I had um a question more about the
the men that cheat on their wives yeah
but that's why would you would you say
those men um
would you are they like what percent
would you say are in like sexless
marriages
out of every like maybe like around the
75 percent really yeah because like most
of the time he's like oh we've got kids
and after the 30s like um they're what
the sparkle wasn't there anymore
and then she stopped sleeping with him
or it's mutual it's mutual most of the
time then like in most of cases like
it's a her not
feeling comfortable with herself enough
to go to the men most of the time as
well because like they get
you know like I think like the selfish
team of a woman depends as well because
on the environment you've got at home
like uh yeah I need to love myself to
love someone else but like if as well
like the man with uh with whom I'm
living with
doesn't make me feel love
I agree with that I think that's what my
love team go I think I'm team go because
I think as a woman if you can sense that
your man isn't being faithful
no matter how much self-love we give
ourselves it we automatically think
what's wrong with me why am I not good
enough what do I what does she have that
I don't this this all these thoughts run
through our brain and that knocks you
confidence so obviously like you can't
be in a happy home in a happy
environment no matter what your husband
brings to the table that does something
to a person mentally and that's why I'm
just team girl sorry Bianca what about
you
I mean I agree with Rue
um in terms of like a high value man I
think it depends on what you call like
class that as because if you're going
around saying I'm a high value man are
you really if you're just going around
doing anything that you would want to do
I feel like yeah
they still are high value men no they
still are yeah but so I feel like so you
say are you really and the answer is yes
they still are but who says this the
women by picking them through sex
I get that sometimes women don't
they're extremely clear
I just don't so I would say like if
Drake went out and said I'm a high value
man I would say yes he is because he has
a plethora of women
but then it goes back to what you deem a
high valued man yeah but you're you're
just trying to shift the definition of
high value man aren't you you're trying
to make it more cuddly and friendly like
oh he's a really nice guy he's like
super honorable and blah blah blah but
but the truth of the matter is like as
Pearl said I mean if the market is
selecting for guys like that like Drake
that that indicates that he's high value
okay in the definition that's most
commonly accepted okay so if you revert
it back to like say say you have a
daughter right she turns 18 she comes to
you and says Dad listen I've started
dating this guy things happen he's
dating whoever he's sleeping with
whoever would you deem him a high value
fan
I'm sure I wouldn't be happy about that
in that scenario but that doesn't that
doesn't detract from the fact that in
terms of societally that dude is still
gonna be if he was Drake or somebody
like that he's still going to be
regarded generally as high value I mean
my feelings as the father would not
really undermine that if my daughter
came home with Drake or I don't know
which one that's so that's so well I'm
gonna check her hand like
I was dating a footballer yeah I would
say what did you expect think of me yeah
it's like you see them in the media they
all cheat usually yeah um typically when
men can cheat they do
and um I don't know why you would expect
a man that has beautiful women thrown at
him every single day to be faithful and
if you don't want that why would you
pick a footballer I don't understand
that how did you pick that I do agree
with that but I think it's more of the
fact that if you're choosing to marry
someone if you know that you want to be
living a certain life why would you
accept and like be like closed off but
you're not actually closed off what do
you mean like if you're going to choose
to marry someone as a footballer if
you're going to marry someone don't
marry them if you know that you want to
live a different life no now they call
themselves polyamorous yeah but I would
say don't marry the men that are most
likely to cheat if you don't want to be
cheated on okay so why pick them how
value men don't have to be polyamorous
if you switch it round right exactly and
say okay the woman the woman is sleeping
with so many different men she's a horse
would that man exactly she's not high
value she's a [__] she's a [__] yeah
why is it called why is it called value
if like if you're sleeping with loads of
different women then your values aren't
actually High well in my book there's
like values it's valuable it's valuable
yeah it's valuable it's not with high
value it's valuable it's valuable but
even you know like um high value men so
it's like okay women want to sleep with
high value men and whatever whatever
this high value in this Society is I'll
give you I'll give you the definition
really quick okay so and this is from
Kevin Samuels this was his definition so
you know it's going to be different
based on who you talk to I would say
it's the women or the men that women
pick but 10K a month other men must
accept you as high value you have to
have a network of high value men you
have to be visibility LinkedIn level and
you have to be useful to others in the
group okay so that's that's what sorry
go ahead finish it okay cool so I'm not
gonna even say high value when I'm
saying this but if you're a woman and
you know that the man is sleeping with
um lots of women and he's got a lot of
money more time I'm that girl getting
into that relationship is not looking
for relationship she's also looking for
something out of it because if you know
the man's gonna be sleeping with
multiple women and he's got money you'll
be having sex with him maybe for the
money that's why when they get kids and
they feel secure and it's like we've got
a family you're saying a lot of them
feel lonely because they're not having
sex with them anymore because you're
going to stay and you're still gonna
give me money you're still going to
bring your high value and you can have
sex with other women and I don't care
because I don't actually love you
so that's why I feel these high values
I'd like to make an argument the men
that sleep with you are not high value
they're just Rich uh well because a high
value man can go out and get it his damn
self you got to pay you well like if I'm
being
fairies like like a high value man trips
over women yeah they don't they don't
have to do [__] on the side so why why
does a high value man need so many women
because it's still high value because
that's how men are they don't do it
because it makes them feel better see
people get this [__] up they try to
guilt men but like and say oh you're
insecure one second they say oh you're
insecure you got to sleep with all these
women to get validation [__] men
like to [__] let's let's yeah we all
know let's call it space yeah it's not
like because what women try to do is
they try to guilt a man into acting the
right way like oh I would this girl
I wouldn't pick um and I completely
understand that but but my argument to
that is if you were head over heels in
love and you had genuine desire for that
man as bad as it might hurt you you
would stay and so would everybody on
that couch and that is true because
as much as you hate him for doing it you
know deep down if you were dating some
slump he would do it if he could and
women misinterpret the inability to get
a woman for loyalty and it's [__] so
let's call spade a spade it's true yeah
I don't think I'm a mistake the
inability I think they know of course
absolutely no it's a [__] test they're
like oh a good man would do this and
this and if the dude's a [__] enough to
give in to it then they got him but the
truth is right after that they get
enough of him after a few years of
marriage they end up texting a high
value man behind her back or his back or
even South America they just go to
something like um My Religion for
example if they do something called um
sweetening of the person
um so I'm South American obviously I'm
from Venezuela and my religion is
which is a phalange of the spiritually
sticker be the beliefs and stuff like
that so like oh yeah I'm from the famous
religion of macombas
and I had and I had so many women coming
to me because I read tarot card I read
parrots and everything
and I've had oh yeah no my my husband is
cheating on me I'm gonna do like that
there's some women that they don't use
judgment because like I am completely
against it yeah but the crazy thing half
of those women have open Instagram
accounts with thought pictures on them
the same women that complain about being
cheated on get attention from men all
the time I know so it's like a lot of
times like women will act like we're so
much better than men because you know
they cheated maybe we didn't in a
relationship but a lot of times we cheat
in a different way we cheat by getting
attention from men but the get out
clause is always it wasn't physical or
not right the get out close is always
well yeah but she didn't do anything
physically he did but I agree with you I
just I don't think it matters no I don't
think about is either but I'm just
saying Society that's that's their get
out of clothes you ever look at Haley
Bieber's Instagram account this is Haley
Beaver this woman bagged the guy that
every girl want who like come on who had
a crush on Justin and their teenage okay
yeah
if it was okay I'm tall so it wasn't me
but I knew how the girls did she yeah
she got him and what look at her
Instagram account it's literally ass
picture butt picture lingerie picture
and this is the woman that got the man
that everybody wants well Haley B but
and Justin's relationship that was
completely formulated like if you see
the clips on YouTube and the crazy
sightings that they were together they
were never like five meters away from
each other for throughout the whole
childhood but I think going back to this
picture thing on Instagram if you are a
genuinely pretty girl and you give off
those nice Vibes you are gonna get those
attention from those males but it's your
choice whether you feed it or not yeah
true that's it that's feeding it and
then you're part of the problem because
you fed it they shouldn't feel
comfortable enough
to even do that with you yeah but isn't
it feeding it to post those pictures and
to have an open Instagram account where
it meant any man can message you agreed
but you can't go down the path of saying
I'm posting this to feel good to do good
he's [__] those girls to feel good
all right
it's empowering him you know I argue
that that's Justin's fault not her fault
because if he had his frame correctly in
his house that [__] would not happen
what what she wouldn't disrespect him
like that if he called for more from her
so is Justin Bieber's fault not hers you
think it's a disrespect type damn right
I think it's disrespect I don't think he
knows how to manage his girl you know
and create leadership in the household
there's no [__] way a man should
allow that [__] and if he does it might
be leadership he just doesn't care about
that maybe he's secure enough I think I
think he's racing no I don't think it's
a security thing I think his lack of
Consciousness I don't think he
understands what's going on I agree with
that I think I think men should provide
um so you do think this like secure
relationships posting them type of
things I can do it talking to yourself
so you don't think there's like secure
relationships posting them things and
feeling confident about each other it's
not about security it's just about why
would you let your girl have a straight
up marketing billboard of her ass on the
internet
yeah it's absolute [__] and if he
had the right frame with her and she was
truly in love with him she would happy
to take that [__] down that is true and
most men don't see that me and pearl
were talking earlier about a
relationship the God said that
everything was good for the first seven
years and it's those little things right
there that that man didn't see because
he's like oh she slept with another dude
well there's also the girls trip there
was also the post on Instagram there was
also the call from her High School
boyfriend that she got in the middle of
the night no bro she's been telling you
the whole time your frame's off then you
got cheated on because she doesn't
respect you wait what do you mean girls
trip
like she went on a girl's trip to Vegas
yeah that's not something you'd Allowed
no no if your girl's in love with you
and truly in love with you she doesn't
even want to go on a girls trip why okay
so posting pictures as a woman online I
can't do that but you can go and sleep
with multiple women because you're high
value
you don't have to stay
I'll replace you you don't have to call
yourself high value men I I'm not this
first of all I hate Alpha Beta high
value all that [__] any man that's
really about his business does not go by
that and I I personally will never call
myself how about you I think it's cringy
as [__] what I will say is and I respect
your opinion and you're actually saying
something that is good in this right
moment because like
please you're not defining yourself
something you know yeah
[Laughter]
all right so but but what I am saying is
is regardless of how how you place me in
the world I would say this about myself
or any other person that has a girl that
he cares about if her ass and titties
are on the internet that is an active
billboard of marketing to get attention
from other men and possibly through
hypergamy transition away from you to
someone else and if she truly loves you
she will take that [__] down and when
you think about it as well it's the
first time really in human history that
this has happened on such a scale isn't
it if you think about women even a few
well 20 15 20 years ago when was it
there were no women who were who were
putting themselves publicly in that
manner aside possibly from celebrities
which is a slightly different case but
now everyone's got an Instagram account
it's really unprecedented in human
history isn't that what it's it's all
about these days though it's dealing
with reality as it is it's we live in a
day and age where women can make money
off of being on social media
um you know taking provocative pictures
and like that and where you know it's
desirable for men to like have loads of
women chasing after them isn't that it's
not it's not like yeah but it's like
what do you want to deal with those
women as a guy like why would you want
to deal with a girl that's in the club
every weekend no yeah why would you why
would you want to deal with a girl that
wants to do girls trips while she's in a
relationship yeah I think girls trips is
okay like definitely go with your girls
have a good time that's not saying that
you have to be out in the club sleeping
with whoever but for me in if I was in a
relationship you would not catch one
photo of me with my a bomb out tits out
nothing like that that [__] that's foul
to me like I don't like that as a woman
and like I know us girls like we've seen
things and been like what she has a
boyfriend though you know she has a
boyfriend she has a man though you know
it's not right and girls encourage each
other to cheat on those traps yeah you
know you're smiling because you're
thinking of something I can see it I can
see it it's funny because I really think
it depends on your friendships that's
why when you get into relationship it's
so important to look at who are these
like who are these man's friends and who
are my friends that when I have when I
get married I hope that my husband he
also has friends that are married and
you know don't want to cheat on their
wives because show me your friends and
I'll show you who you are no man that
doesn't want there's no man that doesn't
want to cheat on his way um I I don't
believe that fact right I'm gonna find a
high value godly man that is what I'm
gonna find them
bring up the Old Testament
I'm not talking about a man that just
goes to church I'm talking about a man
that has a relationship with God there's
a big difference and I will find no I
don't want to please because there's a
lot of priests that don't have a
relationship with God they just want to
make money from church but the key word
is you said want every man wants to
cheat that's like asking a man not to be
every guy okay
every every man when they see a hot girl
wants to [__] her come on come on
Natural Instinct yeah but that love is
supposed to take over it's about loving
too yeah you might have the desire but
it's about exactly right going out there
exactly right and when a woman loves a
man she doesn't even see other men
that's so true yeah okay I'm not done
though
because a man yeah can love his wife
with all his heart and want nothing more
than be a good father a protector tuck
his children in hold his wife at night
but if you think that he doesn't want to
get [__] on the side you have lost your
mind but why does that side like where
what is the root of that it's how men
are it's Primal it's truly like if I
could snap my fingers right now and make
that feeling go away I think I'd be
worth 10x what I'm worth
and I would do the deal I would pay a
million dollars to make that thought
that was what I was gonna ask next
isn't it harder for you to be high value
and have sex with so many like women
because whenever you understand a real
high value man doesn't have to chase
women women chase him yeah exactly I
know that's the problem right isn't it I
don't want to be a good man it's in your
face
you see like I don't look I'm not trying
to be disrespectful to you guys I'm just
so it sounds a bit discipline then it
sounds to the discipline of the man it's
in your face every day but at the same
time even though it's hard it's still a
thing where okay cool am I gonna do am I
gonna have the discipline not to have
sex with this person let me tell you
what happens to a man I do want to
answer your question because I think
it's important government finishes
though
everything that drives a man to get out
of bed and work his ass off is generally
around the thought of sex just so you
know men build been invent build and
maintain society and pursue the women
okay my man works his whole life to get
himself in a certain place financially
physically all these things the man he
becomes and then at the end of that you
tell him you get one woman forever he
would tell you to [__] off it is very
very hard that's why I know and the
message about you man will tell
his girl was up instead of lie like a
[__] coward but that's why that's why
I feel like the missing piece is
actually God because you say the high
value man will do all these things for
sex but a high value man of God he will
be doing all these things because he
wants to put first God first in his
decision so low value what's the
question yeah but he wants to live out
of you man
exactly but and that's a great point if
if you have two men you can pick two men
a low value man that's gonna cheat and a
high value man is going to cheat which
one are you going to pick because they
both will cheat on you it's better to be
single than to be like cheated or then
you're avoiding the question which one
which one would I pick yeah one is going
to give you a better life children love
you be there for you
I wouldn't I don't want to pick oh you
don't want to I don't want to pick I
would rather be single so you're diverse
kids yeah I'm diverting the questions
at the end of the day
I don't believe every man cheats well
every man doesn't cheat but every Every
Man Has the propensity or the desire to
for variety definitely and that's what I
went to loyalty versus ability yeah I
rather loyalty than love at the end of
the day but I know how men are that's
[__] the end of the day it's not
[__] you're telling me I love a
loyalty than love any day of the week
any day of the month and whenever
Loyalty The Love what
oh my God okay so do you you would you
would date Jonah Hill a guy that looks
like Jonah Hill he's loyal on my front
preference you know how I know she's
full of [__] he's loyal every girl on
this couch has a host of men in their
Instagram inbox right now that would
marry them tomorrow and be loyal forever
they don't want those men do you have
men in your inbox of course everyone
does every one of those men I'm not
denying every single girl wants a
certain type of man but at the end of
the day that's he's not gonna whatever
question out of the girls who here have
who's been in a situationship before
I've been in one so one everyone yeah
okay so what were you doing then yes
ridiculous he wasn't loyal to you that's
love of a loyal to you
don't have to agree with you you know
what though when you are really invested
in someone and you want to put that time
in I completely think that everybody
else is blacked out to me it doesn't
matter what else you bring it doesn't
matter if I'm channeling for that guy
this guy X could come with a gazillion
cars a gazillion houses this and that I
don't care I do not care because I want
that one there and that's the reality
and that's the same reason you won't
leave them that's the reality of it but
but I could be dating a high value man
who has everything in the world if you
cheat on me you're a bum to me sorry
have you ever stayed with someone who
cheated nope never no so other question
um so you said something about uh yeah
you said honesty right so clearly
honesty is not the primary the key kind
of characteristic because you've all got
DMS right so you can all find an honest
a loyal man sorry so
[Music]
so you're telling me loyalty is your
number one characteristic I feel like in
my personal wait I have a question he's
five two but loyal yeah I feel like
completely is the most okay
there we go
into the truth like I'm five nine I
think I think women sometimes work like
the other way around they'll tell you
the least important stuff he's
bro he doesn't he has no job and won't
get a job
as well but at the end of the day in a
real relationship
he's broke but no job but he's loyal
but it's so funny it's hard to find a
broke man that won't cheat exactly I
feel like broken
with one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
do you realize that you find 80 of men
is unattractive not okay not average you
look at eighty percent of men and you
deem them unattractive yeah just you
know we only swipe right on dating apps
five percent of the time so why do women
say men are trash because we're all
sleeping with the same ones so whether
you know it or not
so whether you know it or not
you're doing it I feel like at the end I
do not cool man trash
I feel like the day women scream mental
trust mental trash mental trash but they
go for the same type of men they don't
learn and I have my own values I have my
own principles but at the end of the day
in a generalized form women go for the
same type of men and they want to be
screaming oh this this and that but
that's the type of man that you go
through in the first place like yeah
probably complain what kind of what kind
of man do you go to though you haven't
answered my question what's the number
one what's the number one characteristic
so you said loyalty which was Capital so
let's let's put that to the side so we
know Heart is also important we know
success is important you know their
lifestyle is important I just wanna how
do you screen all these Instagram DMs I
just want a genuine person at the end of
the day
the genuine person who's five who's five
two what if he's really far too
obviously there's obviously at the end
yeah
there's genuine stats for each person
there's just I need it I need a yes or
no
very awkward very awkward can barely
maintain eye contact with you but he's
loyal yes or no because I want someone
that can con but I thought the Loyalty
that was the most important thing
but this thing isn't the only thing yeah
there's things that there's a lot of
things yeah but to be fair you did say
they said what's your most important
thing and you said laundry because it is
but clearly it's not though is it it's
the whole relationship of just the
Loyalty that's the thing there's a lot
of factors in relationship but there's a
lot of factors that come first before
loyalty anyway in my opinion I think
like no one is loyal anymore because
like most of the time I have clients
that where they that they are like oh
yeah my wife doesn't need to know and
I'm like do you really think your wife
is doing something else in this moment
like do you think she's at home waiting
for you
um no she's probably getting someone
else on a dating website to do the same
but like the only thing she's doing it
for free you're paying women always
women always know that we always feel
when something is off it's definitely a
thousand percent true so no so do you
think like so we're talking about
long-term relationships at one point do
you think that a woman's needs from a
man say attention intimacy consistent
like 50 years you're talking about
loyalty right it's the worst thing to
get cheated on do you ever think there's
limitations to that the other thing
there's only so much time a man can give
you is full attention time love intimacy
and you expect him to be monogamous do
you think you're annoying sometimes or
that can fade sometimes
I don't know if I can speak on my side
like for example like my grandfather
he's uh he was because he's not here
anymore and um he was a really really
big man but in Venezuela a really
well-known one and very important but
like at the end of the day he's been
loyal loyal at the front
on paper to my grandmother but then like
at some point when one of my uncles died
he showed up to the to the funeral
saying like oh you know guys I've got in
total 27 kids from different women but
he's always been like true to his kids
like he's always been maintaining them
he's never let them
like being without anything they
everyone has asked for something and he
was there working hard on it and giving
it well that's a great man that is a
great man that is the old style
archetype of the high value man isn't it
yeah yeah I I have a question
um do you guys think that most men would
cheat if given the chance so if let's
say a very very attractive like Margot
Robbie is who I think of
um
Ah that's another girl 's name okay I
can't think of her name but a Margot
Robbie level girl came up to him and
said I'll have sex with you right now
right here most men would say yes of
course yeah yeah does a bear [__] in the
woods yeah
so is it better to accept men as they
are or try to change them into what we
want them to be you can't change a mind
yeah it's gonna be who he shows you but
but you guys when we're having this
conversation the way you're talking it's
like you're trying to change how men are
no no I feel like a man will change for
you if he wants to change yeah
exactly your man has a problem that he's
suffering with but he finds this girl
he's gonna think oh my gosh I need to
change this girl I want this girl in my
life I'm going to change for her but I'm
going to stop that what I'm doing on
this side and I'm this is all I'm gonna
think about so everything that I do from
now is gonna be for that girl and that
is the dream that Disney sold us
I'm a little girl that's
you know but call me naive but that's
what I would like to think you know but
the only thing women want when it comes
down to it the only thing we ask for is
just to be protected and that's it
if you can't protect us and you can't
provide an entire security yeah add that
emotional stability for us we're not
bothered protection from War I need to
know that if I'm out
you know and I come into a problem I
know that it doesn't matter how I act
because I know that I'm going to be
saved because I've got my man there so I
know that he's going to be able to solve
whatever situation happens with me I
need to know that I can come home from
work for a bad day and say babe listen
and just reel it off and I can have that
emotional stability with him ah of
course he wants him to stay loyal she's
still working
you know the truth is you're capping
you've not run into it yet you're too
young but in about 10 years she's gonna
be a ride or die and help him get
threesomes I'm telling you it's going to
happen
like I tried to do it it didn't work I'm
gonna get one of these good ones
they do exist you know no okay do or do
they exist fine yes there's occasional
men that make a lot of money and don't
cheat
but
most of y'all aren't gonna get him
okay
is it better to accept men as they are
or change them into what we want them to
be I'd rather they just don't change
them find your own no no but we remember
we we just established the majority the
majority will not end up with these
magical men that make a lot of money
have women chasing them and then choose
not to cheat most women aren't going to
end up with a guy like that okay PO let
me ask you a question do you think that
if you're deemed more like an attractive
female you run into these problems more
do I think that attractive women run
into cheating more all these all every
problem that we've just discussed do you
think that would happen more as for an
attractive female
um as just someone that's just stayed
yeah you know you bang average I I the
reason I the reason I would guess it
happens to attractive women more is
because attractive women get to deal
with the types of men that most women
want more seriously where like the lower
the lower women like unless they have a
really good personality like usually
they're just side yeah no I agree with
that also that's really the problem
you're running into is because you've
not run into a one percent man yet
because if Drake did that to you you
would stay with Drake
you might not like it you'd hop up and
down a screen especially if he was
emotionally there for you and y'all were
like best friends and like really really
Partners you wouldn't leave Drake get
the [__] out of here nah you see me
right that's different not because
it's Drake you know what it is no the
problem is is that you're dating a bomb
and you feel like the the trade-off
is sexual exclusivity so when you find
out he's cheating on you that's the one
thing he was supposed to give up y'all's
relationship for you to be with him now
you find out his broke bomb ass is
cheating on you on top of that then
you're [__] pissed
if men want an Untouchable woman you
have to be Untouchable yourself
what do you mean men want an Untouchable
women most women have been touched by
many men
[Laughter]
but don't look like you have a person
that's all I'm asking why would you want
that why would you want to be with a
girl that you know that saw everybody
else because they can hide it what are
you talking about like in the
relationship he's got she's got to be
faithful in the relationships yeah
Untouchable in that sense but like your
your past as well like I don't know
men don't want women with a past like I
agree agreed but women want men with a
past
why not but you said you know there's a
difference between a virgin and an
absolute man there's a difference
there's like a reason if the man knows
that you don't want a manhole he will
just lie about his body count of course
yeah but let's be clear about the guy
that that's barely not a virgin it's not
because he doesn't want to be a man
[__] it's because he cannot achieve
such status so why would you want to so
you'd want to be with the guy that could
get other women because women don't want
men that other women don't want
yeah I agree so any guy that you deem as
high value whatever your criteria is
necessarily going to be a guy who has
had a past who has had other women
because otherwise hell of a past exactly
because otherwise his value is not gonna
he's not gonna mean anything but as a
woman you find that out about the guy
you're interested in it changes nothing
no the first thing that pop will pop
into a woman's head is so what's so
special about me then what's so special
about what like the girls who the girls
who sleep with Leonardo DiCaprio
probably nothing
I don't stand with those girls at all
because I think they're all silly you
know so when he's got the headphones on
he's listening to music and she's riding
him and he's just like looking at his
watch
this is what you said you said what's so
special about me most women aren't
special
no I'm like seriously what what do women
bring in 2022 that is special nothing do
most women have a cookbook
or do most women really know how to
cater to a man no are most women virgins
on their wedding day no so what what do
most women bring in 2022 that is special
but why is it all about what we can
offer why is it always because because
when when you're talking when you're
trying to sell a car if you're trying to
get married right then please I'm not
saying that women are cars it's just an
analogy
but but if you're trying to sell a car
you have to study the buyer and figure
out what the buyers want and that's what
men want
it all became like a competition between
men and women between everyone and
because like oh I need to show off that
I know how to do this and I need to show
off ha I need I can do that but better
you know you don't think that if you're
trying to get married you should
demonstrate that you have wife skills of
course yeah like who has them at the end
of the day not everyone not many women
in 2022 no but you know what though have
you ever read the book uh why do men
love [__] oh yeah that was written by
a single author that is still singing
that book is on my bedside table that
was my Bible a few years ago like right
next to her astrology set
you have been misled my dear but you
said you've never been in a relationship
so it doesn't work no that's I've been
in this that would be I've been in it I
thought that was no it was pretty teeth
I've been in a relationship but like nah
like if you're not showing me how you
can protect me and how you can provide
for me I'm not cooking you a meal get
lost
but why would you be with that guy in
the first place
welfare's but
but you know like for example to one of
my exes once I and he's um it was like a
slightly recent relationship and um I
was like you know I prepared like his
favorite dishes because I know how to
cook because unfortunately my
grandmother taught me how to do it how
do you say unfortunately because then
like yeah no I know for my friends is
good but like for then someone else
who's not appreciating it like what is
it gonna be good why are you picking
guys that don't appreciate it because
then I found out like later on that he
wasn't really appreciating it like and
and you know like I found out that he
cheated on me and like because I got
messages everywhere of people telling me
because like you know seems like
sometimes people has to come to you and
tell you what and where like he's
probably making mistakes pause for a
second how did he not appreciate it no
he did because like he was like oh my
God this is one of my favorite dishes
that you can make and I was like all
right so that didn't tell me like what
have you done today and he lied and I
was like so why would you lie to me when
you asking me to be honest to you and
I'm like because hand of the truth I can
trust me I have I've been doing so many
things and he thought in his head that I
wasn't enough strong enough to handle
that fear but you left him because of
that issue yeah because like so you
weren't strong enough to handle that
issue because like you know what like um
yeah um I call [__] but why would
she stay women make up reasons they
leave men when they just fall out of
love with them yeah so if you're really
in love with him you wouldn't have left
them
um well yeah but like you know by the
way cooking's overrated men don't care
about that anymore no I'm not no I'm
gonna talk I have ubereats
but I'll tell you I don't think it's
like people act like it's like some
special thing yeah I think it's it's
like a it's like a normal thing that
would endure you to a man right yeah for
example if I cook you a meal you owe me
a relationship now you owe me like for
example like that's a nice thing to do
for someone right whatever you know what
they say I love you but I love myself
more so that's why I leave yeah and
because
um you know and I had meat and I admit
I'm still in love with that man he's the
love of my life but like but you left
them yeah because I love myself no
because I love my I love myself more did
you leave because he cheated would you
say would you say that's selfish if
valuing him
wouldn't you say that's selfish to love
yourself more no because like you you
need you know like everyone says like
you need to love yourself before you
love someone else everyone doesn't say
that women say that I don't know yeah
single single women say that until that
you need to love yourself before a
relationship and if you want to start a
family what do you have to love more of
the family your kids yeah yeah you're
right the family the kids and so it's
like if you're already just
demonstrating before you're even with a
guy that you need to love yourself more
than the relationship and it's like
selfish you know because your kids are
going to be friends if you're in love
with him yeah you should call him on the
show live
I'm just trying to get around the idea
that you said you you love this guy and
he didn't tell you something he was
dishonest to you
but you could handle the truth but you
you fell out over this issue even though
you know you've just shown that he
should have lied to you yeah but like if
you admit something I can deal with that
but if you're telling me no I've been
doing this instead of that and then I
know what you've done like surely now is
when you actually build the trust by
showing you can handle the truth right
saying hey you don't need to lie to me
anymore we can this is where you get to
negotiate and compromise
right
I mean I don't lie for example if
valuing yourself meant like no if
valuing them meant disrespecting
yourself would you still carry on doing
it do you think that's what it is
because we live in a world full of girls
that put their ass and titties on the
internet every day I am the first one if
I'm valuing yeah yeah so what you're
saying is absolute [__] you weren't
in love with that man you value yourself
your sex worker let's let's call it
straight there but like uh I love you
myself I Leave You for Cheating you're
asexual I will admit I stopped doing it
while I was with him because he out
YouTuber and I tried too but then I went
back to it because because I can't get
enough of it and I don't mean it to
disrespect you but when I you can't get
enough of it oh yeah no does it work
yeah in a professional sense or like
yeah it's fulfilling literally yeah
every every hole you need to get back
with this guy that guy really changed
but another another strand of this
though is is what is perhaps what Justin
often talks about which is that um if he
was genuinely high value he would have
been upfront with you at the beginning
because you're saying that he lied about
it or he he concealed it whereas
actually if he'd have said up front
listen you know you're my main girl but
guess what yeah that would have been
perfect from my point of view I would be
I was like you know if you were telling
me from the beginning like oh look I
want to do this yeah but and not use my
job against me I could have thought
about it because otherwise it wouldn't
even mean like and you know what like we
can be polyamorous everyone is doing it
let's try
I think maybe that's what we need to
start respecting a little bit more as
opposed to loyalty it's just the honesty
the honesty yeah it's just you know
because I don't yeah and I don't like to
have someone else to comments but here's
the truth though because if a man came
to you and you truly loved him and he
set you down got everything out the way
and you were needed me and he looked you
dead in the eyes and said listen I
really care about you obviously I'm
gonna see other women there's no way
I'll ever have feelings for them I want
to take care of you completely I want to
be the man that makes your dreams come
true let's go to the dark side of the
moon no I'm gonna be the rock that your
emotional ways crash into I am there for
you I am in love with you let's have
kids I'm gonna have sex with women every
now and then she that girl's delusional
she doesn't know
and and he tells you the truth instead
of being a coward see the problem is you
don't like a man that's going to be a
coward and lie behind your back because
he's too much of a [__] to tell you the
truth you know the truth you know the
truth from the jump that every man wants
to do it it's the respect of sitting you
down and telling you the truth
furthermore most often when a woman
truly truly loves a man she does not
want to sleep with other men at all it's
not this oh you get to do it I want to
do it too because she's so in love with
the man she just wants to be with a man
so
in that in that way I really respect
what you said because it is true in a
lot of women when a man has the balls to
actually tell the truth will in fact
stay because they know they can go get
with the next guy a little bit shittier
life and then get lied to from a coward
I think it comes from the idea and this
might be controversial but it's the idea
that
life's not fair this is how it is men
and men I don't know this is how women
are women if you're going to be men and
men and men that's how they're going to
be so if you if you if you're man enough
to say look this is this is this is the
truth this is what you're gonna have to
deal with I love you but this is what it
is
I would take that any day over well the
issue is it's a Marketplace isn't it you
know and it's very unromantic and it's
very sanitary crew to say but the
reality is that dating sex relationships
it's a big Marketplace out there right
so the guy who is high value who has
options he's good he's gonna exercise
those options in most cases right now
every guy wants to would like to have
multiple women not every guy's going to
be capable of achieving that so you're
going to get some guys who are sort of
lowered down in the hierarchy right you
could date them or you could marry them
and they would probably be you go to my
trans girl okay one one thing I think
people keep on missing with this is that
maybe you're not really even messing
with the high quality people maybe it's
just a lot of mediocre but good looking
people who have convinced themselves
that they're worthy of the ultimate
commitment and love and attention from
each other when you are you're all as
mediocre as each other right so if
you're dating athletes and rappers who
are known for being promiscuous they're
not particularly men of high stature in
terms of character and you're in a short
skirt an after party you're not
particularly why from material right
then so why why do we kind of convince
ourselves that we don't need to
compromise and work for what we want
because I think men understand that you
have to work to get the the woman like
the the one but I never hear women talk
about all the things they need to do to
qualify for the man they actually want
it seems like you don't want to
compromise he loves you must be faithful
he must have this he must have that he
must be loyal or most of the time they
say it when you're not around there most
of the time they can say it when you're
when a man is not around there we don't
have to explicitly state to you what we
you know that's something we do in
ourselves and with our girls and out of
curiosity what do you think that men
want
me personally
I think men want
an outlet an emotional Outlet
when they come home you know and when
they've had a shitty day and whatever I
think they want an emotional Outlet I
think they want someone that they can
like
it's it's difficult
can you can you listen I need you five
things five things that I think you
think
no I'm gonna have you do it and then I'm
gonna have Alex do it yeah so I'm gonna
pick two two yeah so
an emotional Outlet what else emotional
Outlet
I think they want a mother
you want a mother I think the one
I do I will go as far instead says
stability I think they do want stability
I I know they do silly things but I do
deep down believe that he wants
stabilities what's one skill that a girl
would have to have or like treat watch
him at first yeah for a man that like
what would he value
don't say ironing you know what today's
date I'm just gonna say a bean B's
mother be his mother that's what men
just get rid of this book listen
Okay this is the most delusional [__]
I've ever heard in my life you were
describing a child I think she's
described
to say to a man that you're going to be
his mother I think it's that where you
see like the modern feminism that ego
coming yeah that like you you look at it
she's definitely because if you want to
play the mother then you must on some
level look at him as your son right
which is a disrespectful to do you date
men that are children no no but that you
just said
no I think I think she's dating Italian
I think that a lot of men do have some
really deep-rooted issues that stem from
the family environment and where they've
grown up and who's been around and if
they've had a father figure if they've
had a mother figure I think a lot of
issues that they deal with in their
present modern day relationships those
stem from that's the type of men you've
dated no I'm not saying that but I'm
just saying I'm asking you from seeing
my girls and how I've seen other peoples
and other people's relationships you've
dated so they don't have those issues so
I'm asking about you in that past yeah
but that's something that I've
recognized like my mum um she's a lawyer
and she deals a lot with like nasty
relationships and stuff so I've learned
how to kind of navigate through that so
why do why do you think you attract
those men
do you know what I'll tell you why I
attract those men because I'm a fixer
that's what type of person I am I like
to fix people and you've got that
motherly you got that motherly Yorkshire
accent as well
don't worry about it so it's it's
there's nothing it's it's just that
you're a fixer I just think I'm a fixer
I naturally like to tend to people and
tend to people's emotions and I like to
know that you're all alright and that's
just naturally who I am if I can't fix
you but if you keep giving me problems
I'll try and fix and fix and fix and fix
and fix and fix and if I can't fix it
can I have an example of a problem
um
let me think let me think
I just you kept saying fix and fix I
thought there was like this would be
easy
well the first problem is coming home
and crying to you in the first [__]
place what the hell what the hell are
you gonna do about it right not crying
like that but I'm an emotional Outlet a
man's job is to be the mountain that a
woman's emotional waves crash into if he
needs you to be strong enough to go to
work the next day you need to find a new
man or find a man in general but then
that leads into toxic masculinity
doesn't it
has emotions
okay yeah cool so how about he keeps
them to himself and maybe talks to his
colleagues at work about fixing the
problem not coming home like a little
[__] to his wife if he can't make her
feel safe truly feel safe you think him
coming home and telling you about his
problems at work safe and protected
you're gonna feel safe and protected
he's supposed to be the [__] hero
he's supposed to have charge of the
situation coming home and crying to you
like a little [__] is going to do
nothing but dry your [__] up I'm
telling you right now you're wrong not
crying yeah crying to his mother I think
a man has to be comfortable enough to be
able to tell him enjoy your cats I'm not
saying no I'm not saying that you don't
I'm not saying tell me but I'm just
saying that I want you to know that you
can talk but exactly
but it's a double it's like a
double-edged sword because you also said
that you're mothering him and that you
keep having to fix these problems so why
would he bring the problems to you
that's what you said you said you kept
having to fix the problem and fix and
fix and fix no I'm saying like within me
like if I can't feel like you don't have
a problem and maybe that is the man I
attract I don't know but like I I that's
who I naturally am I'm a fixer like if I
can see a problem I'll just try and try
and chip away at it and chip away until
I get to the root of it and then it
sorted see I I personally I interpret
what you say with like such an undertone
of disrespect because to fix someone you
must think that they are broken on some
level and to think of yourself as their
mother you must think of them as a son I
I feel like I hear a lot of undertones
of like I don't really rate this guy and
he's kind of my project when I look at
him as like something that I kind of add
new bits onto a garage workshop and then
I think women a lot a lot of the time
use that as a defense mechanism because
when they break up they say oh he had
all these issues you know he couldn't do
anything he was always crying XYZ I
think if you're gonna support someone
you have to respect them and if you
respect them you wouldn't you wouldn't
say I think an old school woman wouldn't
say oh I'm always fixing my husband's
issues yeah I mean he cries to me at
night I'm definitely his like mother
figure you would never say that because
you respect him as a man completely if
you were such a high value man then you
wouldn't even have to have those
problems to fix exactly everyone well
everyone has problems everyone's having
problems that's how they picture of
course but then you saying that you
can't come home and like if you came
back to your girl and saying oh babe
this happened this happened is that
you're automatically a [__] like
everybody has problems yeah but I was
saying that based on what you said
because you said that you kept having to
fix these problems that's what you said
no that's right so so I'm saying based
on that why would a guy bring you his
problems if you you said yourself you
don't like that you keep being a fixer
no I'm not saying that I don't like
being a fixer I'm just saying that's who
I know that's actually I'm like that's
the energy I vibrate is I'm just a fixer
like but that's not even like in
relationships that's like even a
friendship my life that's my friendship
like if if I'm having an argument with
one of my girls and her kind of vibe is
like okay I need to step back and shut
myself out of this I don't work like
that I'm like come on bro we need to try
this we need to fix this I'm going to
give you some advice real quick and I
hope you don't take this disrespectfully
I think you should burn whatever that
book why men love [__] but burn that
on a bonfire and read a book about
divine feminine Etc because I think you
have a naturally strong feminine energy
but what's going to happen is you're
going to get used up you're gonna go to
the club and give all these feminine
energies to guys who go to the club
every day and run through girls and
after you've finished using the app
you're going to convince yourself that
men are trash man ain't [__] and that
you need to change and you're gonna
adapt more and more toxic behaviors on
until at 28 none of no trace of the
woman the woman right here who said
she's a fixer exists because you've been
used up and disrespected for about five
six years so I would say work on your
strengths and develop that feminine
energy for sure but like I would say
don't put yourself in situations yeah
but like I mean you've never you will
never cry to you about his problems he's
gonna go to someone else because like
trust me I had so many men then that
they were crying in my shower and I was
like all right what I what what am I
doing now I'm really not crying
prostitute showers either
no they don't they [__] don't bro
like they don't okay
no you've got a clue and you know them
because like everyone comes from trauma
everyone has trauma I've got trauma she
has trauma she has trauma she has trauma
probably he has trauma and you have but
a man but a man has a responsibility I
don't know I want to say I don't claim
trauma I'm so sick of hearing about this
trauma I don't know trauma trauma's
supposed to be coming back from War
that's a trauma supposed to be it's
supposed to be I had a real traumatic
situation not my ex-boyfriend cheated on
me
not my parents weren't around enough and
I have some attachment style that nobody
gives a [__] about because nobody cares
about your problems like it's just I'm
so tired of hearing about this trauma do
you know how do you call it yeah because
like people call it problems I mean
problems but it's not trauma shoes they
used to they used to use the word trauma
when men came back from war yeah for pts
and now women have claimed the words and
use it for freaking everything
do you agree with that term mental
health dude is that something
I think there are exceptions but I think
in 2023 the majority of people that
claim mental health do not have mental
health
today in today's day and age a lot of
people do claim it I think that
everybody everybody's depressed
everybody's anxious everyone's this and
I feel like it's just all on the
internet they believe everything they
read
if a lot of people turned off their
phone lived in the real world went
outside spoke to people they would be
100 these girls are on Tick Tock okay I
think dopamine yeah and then they
convince themselves that they are
depressed anxious
and feminists yeah feminist it's not
mental health it's low IQ
it's low IQ because they're too stupid
to realize that they're getting lied to
nobody here Pearl's dead on if you put
your phone down and had a real life and
how real things going for you mental
health will go out the window wait so
are you relating medicine
with a low IQ I think a lot of the
people that buy into [__]
let them finish go ahead like people
that buy into the [__] and they get
told that they have a health problem
when really they're just fat and have a
[__] life if they turn their life around
their mental health problems would
likely go away no I mean bad like
someone so say someone says like yeah
I'm dealing with depression if someone
came along and said that would you
relate that then to low IQ no something
you're saying no I think falling for it
and believing now yeah of course you're
not putting a bad mental health State
and a low IQ I would call that person
probably lazy right because they're
depressed because they have a [__] life
well victimhood has become like the the
you know the currency of the realm I
knew someone that was super depressed
but he was like 300 pounds I'm like what
do you expect what do you expect right
you can't see your dick I'd be a
depressed too I go cry in her shower if
I couldn't see myself
all of that to decide imagine like
you're rich you've got like good money
good friends good family yeah in the
side like keep going you're just happy
you portray your happiness you're like
extremely happy but just within yourself
you're sad like would you believe that's
Mental Health
if you've been you've been defeated by
your comfort I would challenge you that
I think that's what happens a lot of
people think oh if you just give men
things that they should be happy and if
they're not they're meant things it's
about feeling happy within yourself like
okay let me I get what you're saying I'm
gonna land yeah I think I think people
miss the fact that a lot of mental
health and and mental fortitude and
self-esteem comes from challenges it
comes from overcoming so when you take
that away from people especially you see
this in affluent kids when you take that
away from people what do you have
literally a kid with money yeah and no
purpose yeah no problem so I agree with
him on IQ I wouldn't even describe it as
low IQ because I think it's how we're
raising people now I think was I grew up
in a village in Nigeria so I come I come
from a place where like silence was my
base yeah in London growing up here you
don't have silence you have a phone from
age eight from age eight you're you're
completely exposed to this internet with
polarizing views and XYZ it's how do you
expect a young person to navigate that
and actually form coherent rational
opinions self is different from the rest
of the
have their Tick Tock and talk about
right I've got this I've got that I've
got this thing and you know you need to
have a label it's like right what's the
next thing yeah so I think there's
almost like a competition for it now
yeah and I'll tell you what I'd add to
what they both said I challenge you to
do this go find a man that makes a bunch
of money yeah he's in jam up shape yeah
got great style great life great friends
travels and ask him if he's [__] sad
I think happiness and joy is like two
complete different things I feel like
happiness is like a fleeting
um a fleet in feeling that you will feel
when you're doing all these things but
you know you have true Joy when
obstacles can come your way and you
don't travel no more you're maybe not um
having sex with all these people but you
still feel this peace within you and
that's the difference between like joy
and happiness so yeah I think generally
we need to I don't know I think
especially in today's day and age we
need to walk a bit more in our ignorance
we have a problem doing that with
accepting that you know what especially
at my I think a lot of people are
walking in their ignorance
ignorance is bliss if you really want to
learn about cheating huh yeah so yeah
it says the woman with a high volume
fulfillment and happiness are completely
two different things I think
fulfillment and happiness yeah yeah I
mean happiness is a temporary mental
state right fulfillment is a bit more
natural I wanna I wanna get through the
rest of the panel because I think the
original question was was the girl
should the girl have stayed oh yeah
so I want to get YouTube I think you
guys both said leave did you say leave
no I will stay for like um
I've been treated with them honestly
like I'm honest to you you honest to me
okay like let's do something else you'll
say Okay me
um no she's she's an accident on you
um
to be honest I feel like
because he for example the footballer
situation
um
if you're gonna go into a marriage you
shouldn't be having to cheat sudden it's
I would leave because I'm expecting a
man to be with him even if he's the he's
the footballer what if he told you up
front
if he told me out front like I'm
cheating yeah I'm going I'm still gone
okay because you cheated on me and
that's not what I wanted from you is it
cheating if he tells you
you're so cheating like regardless of
what you've done or whether you're going
to do it or whatever it is
if you have those thoughts you're not
happy with me so well every man see
everyone's got those thoughts I would
bet every dollar in my bank account that
neither one of you would leave Drake
that's just like the greater myself
because why am I letting a man cheat on
me yeah why are you flexing on all your
girlfriends going on living in a mansion
no it's not about that because if my
girls had happy relationships completely
living normal lives and I was seeing
Drake they'd say Rue yeah you're living
this mad life but he's cheating on you
you don't love exactly it's not real
it's not real well that's why that's why
women keep I like how she I'm sorry I
don't mean that's okay I like how you
let your friends Define your
relationship with your man instead of
thinking for yourself
it's literally what you just said I'm
just saying like that's literally what
you just did I'm just saying as an
example no as an example you literally
just said I I would disregard how I feel
and take in consideration my friend's
opinion and I'm dating Drake is that not
true no matter who I'm dating it doesn't
matter it does matter it matters how you
feel about the situation and I would
feel no but we're going to get divorced
in three years I would feel the com yeah
but I would feel completely the same I'd
be betraying myself
everybody here said they're in a
situationship before so you've done it
it's interesting because in this case
you get more so you get you get
everything paid for okay and and you're
married and you're married to him
um and he does the same thing that the
guys you you have seen before have done
you'll be opposed to Define you like
just because you've done something
before it doesn't mean that's true
you're not gonna like do it past counts
with a man I'll tell you that past the
past tends to repeat itself so no I mean
if it's something that you say you don't
want to do like you don't have to do it
anymore you're the TR you decide yeah
but men don't forgive you for your past
of course
if I mean like your past doesn't Define
you in the point of no but I mean like
in the point of
um you just said oh you've all been in a
situation [__] so like why wouldn't you
be in a situationship with someone that
you know is giving you more money no my
point is it's cap like it's it's cap
because everyone here has done it that's
why I don't believe it yeah but then you
wouldn't be looking for love in that
situation I'm saying I'm saying in a
situationship you guys got less out of
it because I'm sure situationship it's
you're usually not being taken on crazy
days you're not but then you learn from
it so you choose whether you accept this
like the same reason of a man cheating
on you sir I I know it's a boy and a
girl that are in a relationship but he
actively cheats on her and he tells her
love her this is what's happening
she chooses to accept it and move on at
the end of the day that's her choice she
can't come to me and cry about the
situation because she accepts him she
chooses it she chooses that lifestyle
but if she didn't choose that lifestyle
she wouldn't be with him you don't think
it's a choice by dating a footballer
yeah it is a choice so that was my point
when the question
and the question I'm saying was she was
she wrong to leave or should she have
stayed and I'm saying she picked that
lifestyle by picking a guy that is going
to cheat yeah at the end of the day as
you said maybe all Ballers and all
rappers and all these people maybe they
might not cheat but I said maybe the
majority of them do cheat and do this so
what about them individuals that don't
cheat that are rappers or things you
still have to get to know people right
but it's like this is what women do it's
like you're looking for a lottery ticket
that doesn't exist because it's not you
like the majority of you it's not it's
not going to be you you know because
like the magical woman that's gonna
change this guy that has always to
achieve everything
what makes
like I know uh some of our opinions
differ but like how come your you think
like this like what yeah do you know
what I mean like why do you think like
that why why do I think that cheating is
natural demand because 8 000 years ago
um 17 women reproduced for every one man
so I think it's actually really common
for um and natural for them to be
non-monogamous I'm not saying that um
every guy is gonna cheat on you I I
don't believe that but what I do believe
is that women go after the men that will
cheat and then they cry about then they
cry about it later and I just don't have
a lot of sympathy like if you're going
after the top 20 percent of that if
you're going after basketball players
um entertainers rappers and you're gonna
cry later that you got cheated on no
surprise oh yeah or even even the top
five percent of men it's like these men
have worked their whole lives to get to
a certain point you weren't with them
when they were broke and now you walk in
and say oh be faithful to me why would
he again it's the problem of it it's the
problem of looking at it in a dignified
way as opposed to looking at in this
sort of sort of more harsh darwinian
sort of um economic Marketplace kind of
a way which is what it really is where
the people who are at the top who have
the more opportunities are gonna act on
those opportunities you know these high
value dudes are going to act on the
opportunities that they have because any
guy would every and this is what we're
saying every guy would want to act out
in that way not every guy has the
opportunity to do so but those are the
top absolutely do and they're gonna
they're gonna utilize that for them and
I'll tell you another thing any goal
will take the opportunity to be with a
guy like that exactly exactly exactly
exactly and another thing that happens
because I see this quite a bit myself in
my inbox yeah is the the average guy
that's coming home every night
when he gets cheated on he gets cheated
on with a guy that's that other dude and
he's sitting there being loyal and being
a good man Etc yeah and and she's
sliding in some footballers inbox yeah
and if he bites and she's foolish enough
to believe it'll be anything more than
just sex then she tried she but she'll
probably just do the sex and
at the same time she would leave him for
that footballer yeah it's ugly it is
ugly and I'm not saying I like it but
it's absolutely true it's the huge
majority but it's not the whole of
females the whole of Mills look I'm not
[__] on women I'm just saying when
that guy gets cheated on by because
women cheat to you no of course and when
they do they're generally not going
Downstream to do it they're going at
least across yeah but mostly they're
going up yeah so I mean it is the harsh
reality that's why when he says
darwinistic it's very it's very
darwinistic in that way yeah but it's an
important message because nowadays
people people idolize celebrities in
such a way that I think a lot of women
don't don't think about stuff like this
really like if I it's true just hearing
you talk right now you've been thinking
for love when you're going for a man
like that like a lot of like I feel like
the woman is not thinking oh like this
is this man's gonna love me like I need
to be loved you know I think she's
thinking I want money you'd be surprised
I'm using rapper's athletes and Ballers
as an example but I see it with the with
girls going after the same guys at
school
or girls going after the same like it
doesn't necessarily mean they have to be
famous but I see girls date the same
guys or go after the same guys all the
time and then cry and whine yeah when
they cheat when it's like yeah you're
getting the same result every time
everybody
that's true and mine is not it's one
we're trying to make amend into
something they're not what at the end of
the day most men if they had women
pursuing them like the top percentage of
men do so these are all like uh there's
um athletes have girls on the side that
that will the like the most beautiful
women you have ever seen nines and tens
begging them to have threesomes you
don't think any man like in 20 years a
man is gonna turn that down or is gonna
turn that down every even a good Godly
Man
that's my point even a man that is Godly
like he's still a man yeah no my issue
is when we go after these men that all
the women want and then were shocked
when they cheat when it's like okay well
why don't you go lower he doesn't have
to make that much money he doesn't have
to be that cute oh well I can't do that
well do you know that's what I think
that's what I think that's something
it's so important for a girl to go
through her single season because I feel
like in that season of just singleness
and like reminding yourself you have to
reprogram your mind of okay I don't I
can't go for these guys anymore and even
if you know in yourself I don't want to
go for these guys anymore any guy that
comes to you that's not like this guy
that you've been going through like
going for since school it's like that
ick to you it's like oh like he's a good
man but do you really want that good man
like you know when girls say he's a good
man you're like oh she don't really like
him he's just good because you know he's
cheating whatever but I said you have to
literally reprogram your mind and say
these are my morals and I have to not
stick with it for like a year did this
happen where you like switched your
morals or like I feel like I'm suing the
process of it because like even some
people talk to me now and it's like oh
this is a good guy man like you know
he's not like the other one by side oh
do you still do you actually want that
how old are you again if anyone 20 oh
wow yeah how old did you think I was
like 25.
I'll tell you why oh okay okay
um so when did when did you switch this
like thinking like you went to church or
something no no I've been in church but
I was always that I wasn't always like
with good per se but it wasn't this is
not to do with God what is it to do with
the people that I've been with and um I
just realized not a lot you you
preferred the toxic ones like you liked
them a little better I think I went
really all like the stage like that yeah
a little face but I feel like it's a
young people thing now if you met a guy
if you had to pick between the good guy
that's in your inbox or this toxic guy
you're thinking of I can see it
you're thinking of someone I don't know
who it is someone someone got you which
is okay every girl's had their heart
broken it's like yeah do you know what
it is so it's like even if you wouldn't
it you just have to tell yourself that
stay away distraction but your heart you
you would still want the more toxic one
I gotta reprogram my heart no but but if
we're being honest if we're being honest
that honest honest I'll go over it but
in my I'm protecting my heart still I'll
see how my bird is up because I'm like
he's not gonna give you what you want
he's not going to give you love he's
going to be doing all the things that
you don't want and ended you up in that
situation after after like this
relationship or whatever whatever it was
you did you go to church was that like
your outlet
I was going to church regardless no but
I mean is that you seem to have had and
you could correct me if I'm wrong some
spiritual like Journey maybe where you
were praying more or like I don't know
what it was yeah that that's quite a
long story
um to be honest but um
yeah funny enough after a relationship I
did get more like
um spiritual and I started talking to
God more and like started like getting
my amazing it's not spiritual it's like
a church it's a Christian it's um no I
don't I don't I don't that's why I don't
call my like I'm I'm Christian like if I
just need to say it easily but I don't
say just Christian because it's I don't
just say Christian because I believe I'm
just a woman of God like I just because
sometimes you can say Christian and it's
such a great area like everyone's
Christian if you go to church if you
listen to your pastor but I believe okay
cool I'll look into my scripture I
actually have a connection with God but
to go back so basically though you're
trying to now reprogram yourself to like
the good guys
um it's not reprogram myself it's not
reprogram to be honest I'm not my mind
right now is not on men like my mind
right now is focusing on myself and when
that person comes I'll know the first
season of singleness
I just want to be single and focus on
myself right now but in the future you
want the good guys in the future I want
the man that's right for me okay okay it
sounded like you said good guys earlier
you said you have to reprogram your
brain so I just to like not like the
people that I was lacking before right
yeah so I'd imagine this is the good
guys right yeah but not in the yeah
no it's not good guys it's the right man
for me that's it like just that you ever
notice that when women talk about or one
a lot of women talk about kind of these
single season and taking time for
themselves it's never any kind of
improvement that benefits the future
partner no for me it is yeah they never
like it's never like I'm training I'm
trying to develop qualities that my man
was like I'm trying to be the kind of
woman it's always like I'm just letting
myself be me you know because maybe it's
something
important Carousel bro let's call it how
it is you know going through this thing
in a season like right it's just a bunch
of dicks
be about your man why should
self-healing be about another person
itself
from what she's 21 years old no
the point of this healing I would
imagine is to become a healthy person
then have a healthy relationship right
yeah but that healthy relationship needs
another person so when you're healing
yourself you're also trying to develop
the quality of feminine that the person
would like so you men understand this
right we don't go to the gym and just
decide I'm just going to be some gym
dude now I want to do better my job I
want to have a better fashion sense I
want to work and always I want to work
on my anger management might understand
this but I never hear women talk about
like the difficult things to me I Define
it as things that I actually take work
like when you talk about the men you
want I never hear about things that take
work like I'm gonna have to learn how to
have a conversation I'm gonna have to
learn how to support him in a way that
still respects him I never hear about
the difficult thing it's always what
comes naturally it's always accept who
you are whatever you are all the time
and wait for the world to come to my
doorstep no it's true because even in my
last patients I was realizing I was the
one always making the decisions or like
in like literally all my past
relationship well not much but yeah so I
was really I was the one making
decisions and that's more of like a
masculine trait yeah so what I had to
realize was how to have a conversation
in a way that was more feminine like
what you were saying earlier like if the
man was to come with his problems
instead of me saying okay cool I'm the
one that has to fix it and think oh
what's the answer to his problem more
like you know what you got this like I
know you can do it like I believe in you
you can do that and letting him come up
with the answer and be the man so I'm
kind of working on things like that a
bit more on like my replies and stuff
because my automatic response would be
let me heal this man so I need to get
out of that before getting into another
relationship can I ask you a question
yeah have you considered that finding a
man that does not bring his problems to
you and solves them for himself might be
the best life for you no 100 but I mean
if he does come to me about a problem
like he's not coming to me to fix it
he's just saying oh this happened not a
thing where it's like oh this happened
what do I do but in fact this happened
but it's like as his woman he's just
knowing he's just venting he's just
saying it but I'm my response should be
you know what you got this that is fine
but it's like if he knows that from past
experiences that the woman is gonna be
fixed is probably fixes problem and he's
gonna feel pity for um like she's gonna
feel pity for him she's gonna want to
stop but if she if he knows that I as a
woman I'm not going to feel pity for him
he will feel comfortable to like say it
I have a question do you want to be
married
yeah I do do you feel like you were
raised to be a wife
um
no in my household no like I was born in
a household with my mom and my dad but
um and they're married and everything
but I spent more time with my dad so
that's why I feel like I've almost as
like such an independent woman like boss
dating all my relationships I'll be
paying for things because I was more
with my dad than I was look up to him
and be like oh
um
I would look at him as my role model so
I'll be like you know I'll pay for the
dates whatever but
um I'm trying to come out of that like
that's the part of my healing stage I'm
trying to okay follow-up question yeah
would you be willing and accepting if a
strong man came into your life and
helped build you into a wife I'm not
ready yet that's why I mean no no no I'm
saying I'm yeah I hear you're saying
is if he came into your life would you
be accepting of him building you into
the wife that he wanted yeah I
definitely will be like that is what I
feel like this healing is for for that
so I'm ready for that um just to show a
hint who on the panel wants to be
married
um
feels like they're a raised to be a wife
I think it depends on the war was
definitely raised to be or how because
especially with my culture I'm South
American like which country I'm South
American Brazilian all right yeah so I
feel like in my culture there's two
sides there's obviously that the side
that everyone talks about that's not
very good and all of this bad stuff but
then on the other hand I've actually
been raised in Brazil and I've actually
grown up in a strict like Catholic
household my mum's always taught me how
to be a wife like from a young age you
would tell me like oh this is what not
really exactly what you have to do but
this is what I mean you have to show
yeah like the traits that a man would
like like cooking cleaning being
supportive yes yeah bring other women
home okay I never agree with but that's
just my personal choice like obviously
in the broader picture I do see men
bringing other women home but in my
personal choice that was something that
that's something I could never run so I
I have a question for the women that
said
um that they want to be wives
um but they don't feel like they're
raised to be a wife do you guys have
married women around you no no I do no
no yeah I do
rub it in
um anyone yeah no you have okay
um have you guys ever sought to like
seek that out
what in what sense what do you mean
because you want to be married right
that's the outcome you want so how would
you learn how to be married
you would look to people that are
married yeah yeah yeah
most of the time but yeah like all of
this I don't think about that I don't
really look back at my past
to I don't know to move forward I just
know what I want for myself and I know
that no but I mean if I wanted to be a
pro Vault like I played volleyball right
I was offered a pro contract in the fall
and what did I do to become a pro
volleyball player yeah almost right the
YouTube thing took off but I had to get
coaches yeah yeah to teach me how to
play yeah yeah yeah no I agree with that
and I think that's a problem with um
society today we don't
I don't know I think people like Kevin
Samuels but he was important because
especially for me he made me
think about what the type of guys I want
would want from me I never thought about
that before I started listening to him
you know he was the first person to say
hey like it's all good think about what
you want as a woman but what about
thinking about what the type of guys you
want would want from you how do you how
do you learn how do you go about
learning what they want and then
bringing that to the table and I think
that's the problem with
with society today it's all about yeah
it's all about well this is how I am and
you know I need to find someone who can
who can match that but I definitely am
somebody that thinks about what you know
the type of husband I would want would
want from me I I um and I acknowledge
that I don't know everything you know
which is why I don't know when people
are talking I'm very quiet I'm like I'm
the type of person where it's like I'm I
want to learn I want to learn yeah what
do you consult what is your source of
information or whether you where do you
kind of get your knowledge not that book
I haven't read that book actually I
don't know
um I think
um I don't know it's just it's just
listening to conversations like this
Kevin Samuels for me was somebody that
really like got me interested in
thinking about this sort of stuff I
don't know I don't know I guess yeah
well there's a huge space online of
self-improvement for men because men
generally recognize you know if the guy
is sitting there and he's not getting
you know the dating life he wants he's
not having the relationships he wants he
recognizes well okay I need to do
something about this the onus is on me
and so then you know they go to the
internet and they find people who are
talking about you know making money or
or going to the gym or you know all of
these different things it's all about
self-improvement I think there's less of
that for women because I mean there is
there is some
um but there's less of it for women
because like surgery yeah plastic
surgery because women are mainly you
know there's a there's a sense in the
culture that women are enough you know
we're so we're I'm enough you know
um that gets said very often doesn't it
and and because women are sort of
pedestalized in mainstream Society the
woman is encouraged to think oh I'm a
princess anyway I'm so I'm I'm
somebody's Queen anyway so I don't need
to do anything and actually really what
we should all be doing is looking at how
we can improve what because I knew that
yeah go in do you want to talk no I was
just gonna say like for me I obviously
I'd love to be married like in the
future I don't think you know I I don't
know a girl that wouldn't want to be in
a happy marriage and this like that but
I wasn't raised by oh I was raised in
the single parent household like my mom
raised me and my brother and she's not
married she never got married to my dad
and I couldn't ask for anything more
like I think I have I took some of the
best morals from her and my grandma
likes really really strong influential
women in my life and I would take those
things that I learned from them into my
into my future marriage and then
anything added is about learning and
picking up from other people that are
also influential in your life you know
whether I'd be friends family who you
see on social media who you see just
around I that's what I think so anyway
are you saying you don't think you
should seek out married women for advice
or you do I'm just I'm confused no no
like I I think it does help but like I'm
just saying it the process is just about
learning if you haven't had that you
know you know what you know what this
sounds like to me right it sounds like
when you ask a student whether they've
done extra reading on the topic and
they're like you know I saw something
I think like Tim was talking about some
of the corridor I think you have to
actively look to understand the divine
feminine and and the role of a woman and
a wife and how that can compliment a man
I think it sounds like it's very it
sounds like you're not doing that but if
you if you want to be honest with
yourself am I looking out like am I
seeking out that information and really
trying to I'll tell you how a man does
it right I've read three or four books
on how to engage with women because when
I was younger I couldn't I couldn't get
down texting game I had me and my one of
my closest friends in uni our whole
relationship is based on us me learning
how to text now text people get no
response and he would dissect the text
and be like you said too much here this
could have been a simple sentence it was
a compound sentence you kind of gave the
impression that you're asking for
permission here and I eventually figured
it out I read The Art of Seduction I
read bang volume one two I read all
these books to try and understand women
and I feel like you need to do a similar
thing to understand what the man you
want to high level man would want from a
woman yeah the problem is Alex when
we're sold these books like why men love
[__] to understand men or the movie
Heat it's it's like what what quality
book is there to understand men the beam
is Led even hitch hitch doesn't even
make sense so he's this Suave guy he
meets a woman who's like got basic
levels of confidence falls in love with
her and then gives up his whole life on
stability to chase her it's a it's a
movie about ego it's it's what these
women like uh these women not baby trap
athletes think are like oh I'm gonna
change him and then he's gonna like drop
everything and that that's the real
message it's not saying I had to change
I had to meet him halfway I had to help
him feel safe that's that's not what
it's saying it's saying you're so cute
that top man will eventually fall for
you for no reason because you're good
enough I I do still think it is a whole
process like I'm like the youngest
person in this room I'm 20 you know I'm
not looking to get married next year
like the whole thing is just a journey
and it's growth and it's about personal
growth and you know the answer the
answer no
but it's like you give this like word
salad instead of just no no but from
someone who doesn't hasn't had that
growing up being in a married household
I'm com I'm happy with what I got you
know I'm I can sit and be comfortable
with that when do you want to be married
by I don't know I don't have a I don't
have it so 45
okay so you you do have a rough okay so
yeah I'd say South that's okay so you
want to be married by 35. yeah I'd say
that was right well I'm not putting like
why is that mad do you want kids because
it clearly it sounds like there's no
woman around you who are saying listen
you're young you're gorgeous this is the
time you set the foundations for who you
want to be it sounds like they're saying
just chill trust me when women get past
a certain age the poor reduces
significantly no absolutely not I
disagree with that like my my mum is so
like you and cross my mum like she's so
strong and I think whether that's to do
with her job or just the fact that my
grandma was also a single parent whether
that's you how old your mom she is 51.
and she has a job yeah and she has
failed as you will
sorry straight up your mom's lying to
you you want to get married at 35.
you wanna have children no I never said
I'd get married at 35 pill was giving me
an estimate and I just said you said you
said yes no she said 45 and I said No
and then she said 35 and you said yes
that's about right yeah yeah too late
too late I'll marry a 20 year old
instead that's fine right look I'm just
telling you like box wine cats that's
your life no I just I don't know
go go to the club
how old is she how old are you I'm 37.
are you married huh are you saying
single wouldn't you like to know well
I'm just saying like but I'm not the one
with the problem you're not the same
though you're not delusion you're not
this and I hate that for you because
you're because you're a pretty girl
that's really smart and I hate that
you're saying these things because you
could probably be a hell of a good wife
and a good mother you're not a stupid
woman I think you're misled It's just
sad to see you're married on your 37
years have you been married divorced
have you got kids I listen let me just
say this I have it all I got it all
I'm almost stressing to you like I don't
want to be mean to you almost stressing
to you that this is like it's the wrong
path like waiting tell me that it's a
wrong person it's your path right have
you got your life together
that's funny that a sex worker is going
to ask well listen here ladies look my
dear yeah I have my life completely
together there's nothing in my life I
would change
while you're being angry now
you're angry about your life my dear
okay no no no
okay I have a question do you do you
think what did you just say
so this
no I I really because I don't want to be
mean to you or anybody and I apologize
if I have I just simply think that wait
until 35 to get married and finding
yourself and sleeping with a bunch of
people is gonna be bad no one said we
were waiting to think you literally just
said that like what is so right about
your path that makes mine wrong no it's
not me comparing myself to you it's just
me saying damn that's gonna not be good
because I see it all the time it's not
because I'm not trying to pick on you I
just see these girls they're on
Instagram they got their boobs out and
they're doing all this stuff and you're
lagging them as well at the same time
like that that's that's irrelevant right
yeah I'm not redeemed right right what
does that matter what are you saying
well he shouldn't be talking like that
then what are you saying true or not
just listen like listen to what he's
saying he actually he actually had he uh
almost half of the stuff he's been
saying but I'm saying just listen before
you get triggered listen I'm just simply
saying that likely you're going to want
to have kids in a family long before 35.
that's all I'm saying for sure that's
what I'm saying and in addition and I
don't mean to cut you off I'm sorry
you're going to want a real man not a
man that's going to come home and cry to
you not a man that you have the mother
that would just make you a broken bird
you want a guy that you can look up to
and you want to be the like the leader
in your relationship yeah absolutely but
I'm just saying like I wasn't saying yes
35 is when I will be no but the but but
the but then the suggestion of like well
I'm not going to learn any of these
skills because I'm only 20. I think I
think the general point is like if you
go to other countries if you know
Ukraine before the the current war and
you know Russia I mean there are women
they're getting married at like 22 23.
oh yeah no no you know it's it's a
societally here we've got this different
idea about it you know but it's not it's
not worldwide yeah okay so you have it
you haven't been raised to be a wife
right that's that's who you said so how
when when do other women usually when
did you start learning to be a wife
would you say at a very young age
just a brief of things like I was
learning how to make simple things like
eggs at the age of eight or nine okay
eight nine
okay so so you're 20. so she's she's
been learning to be a wife for for 12
years so that's kind of wait wait let me
finish she's been learning to be a wife
for 12 years
right now you're behind
so so right because she's you're going
to be competing for the same guys right
because we all want the same men we've
established this we all want about 20 of
men and you can deny it or not but you
do just trust me on this so how how
would you get to a point where you could
compete with her so the thing is just
how you said oh I've been learning to
cook eggs like for like
yeah like not entirely as a wife maybe
just as a woman but natural life skills
so when you said that I was literally
just gonna jump in and say yeah I have
also been taught how to do those things
but not for anybody else other than me
I think that's an important thing the
point was still the same though is that
you're not you're not learning the key
skills and mentalities needed to
maintain a long-term relationship with
with a man but sure
I have the facility
about cooking
cooking cooking is an example of a skill
that comes with it right because you
have to feed the kids you know I know
some guys can afford ubereats but but
but but like my point my point is
you have to learn from wives how to get
along with a man and if you didn't have
that as an example you didn't learn you
don't know and so a lot of times women
we get to an age like 20 21 22 23 and we
don't realize we're behind because all
the other women have been learning this
for 10 years and now we're trying to
play catch-up and instead of you know
and I would just recommend trying to get
women that are wives so you have someone
to learn from I don't know I think it's
maybe my perspective is that if I know
how to do it I know I can do it for the
people like it's not that much
I keep thinking it's about cooking and
it's not about cooking no no no I'm just
saying like if I can love myself and I
can be there for myself and I can
provide for myself how I've been taught
to I can do that for other people but I
think the thing is do you know what the
only thing that I think like I
completely agree with you like when you
love yourself you love other people but
something that I like have been learning
is that the way we love ourselves as
women is not the same way that a man
will want to be loved so it's like so
nobody so it's like you know when you're
giving like the answers that we would
give ourselves like we would give
logical answers to ourselves but a man
like he probably wouldn't want a logical
answer from his woman because I'm not
sure I'm not sure loving yourself is is
is the route to being able to love
somebody else in a relationship it
sounds very solipsistic it's very
solipsistic isn't it it's like oh I love
myself I can nurture myself and
everything but what's that what does
that do in terms of giving somebody
somebody else sustenance marriage is
supposed to be about the family before
you it's not about like it has enough
marriage has nothing to do with
happiness
marriage has nothing to do with loving
yourself it's about loving the family
before I love myself agreed the key
trait is selflessness so that's another
hint that that you're being misled is
that you're saying all the stuff about
self-love but the key trait for a
marriage is selflessness is the man
being selfless thinking of his family
his wife before himself it's the woman
being selfless we have a generation of
women who are being who growing up
thinking oh so me loving myself loving
myself you're going to be loving
yourself for 27. yeah and you're going
to be looking for decent guys after you
you've made all the wrong choices
they're going to realize there's only
like two guys in there who have a
long-term job and who actually like have
are respectable people and those guys
will have 17 women who are all waiting
for that same spot and then they're
going to talk to 32 year olds who will
be getting run through who are going to
be too busy trying to lie to you that
they're having fun when they're paying a
quarter of the salary to therapists
every month right and that's my concern
is that you you if that if that cycle
happens because that that is he
literally just set a cycle that we all
see all the time my concern from you and
this is coming from care I didn't mean
to attack you and if I did I am sorry no
I am simply trying to stress to you that
if you go that route by the time you
meet him he won't want you
and and that and that is just a concern
I'm not saying I'm right I'm saying
there's a high probability concern I
just think my personal opinion is that
if you don't have self-love you've got
nothing yeah hands up let's have
something else and also to know how what
how someone else should loves you as
well
um I have a question what what is
self-love
um appreciation of yourself because I
think a lot of times we confuse
um narcissism with self-love
when I hear you guys talk it sounds very
narcissistic and I'm wait wait wait
before you react wait please please even
even when you're talking about in a
relationship you're saying I'm a fixer
but then what did you do wrong
he did something wrong I had to fix him
yeah I feel like a lot of women like
they're like they think it's like a
one-way thing but it's a two-way thing
and also like with self-love I feel like
a woman to be in a healthy relationship
anyway she does have to love herself
first place base because otherwise the
insecurities would just take over I
agree it would just mess up the
relationship like the devil is a liar
yeah the devil is a liar he's taking a
truth and twisted it in a way that it
led to the wrong decision you know what
it is because it's a worldly it's a love
that like people think love is like hugs
and like kisses and like baths and face
masks but really and truly like loving
yourself is it's a tough love like you
have to love and if you truly love
yourself you're gonna put aside things
that make you feel comfortable
to better yourself I think the best
wives honestly don't really think about
themselves I think about everyone else
for I've never heard like I'm just being
honest guys I have never heard of
someone that I respect and admire as a
wife talk about self-love that's not my
mother
wait wait wait they only they only care
about everyone else like it's always the
woman that's catering to everyone like
going in the drinks getting the like
cooking like the it's just like a
motherly presence it all seems very um
it all seems very modern and sort of
um you know the kind of stuff you see on
Instagram and like you know quotes and
stuff like that it's like if you think
about like my you know grandparents and
stuff like that I mean they didn't have
time for all this sort of like
introspection it was like you know my
grandmother was I think the you know
left school very young had to go and go
out to you know and supporting family
um you know then there was a bloody war
and all this kind of stuff like like
people were people had serious stuff
going on and then you know they had
children and she had to look after the
children my grandfather go out to work
et cetera Etc there wasn't this time for
this like Naval gazing and this sort of
like oh do I do I love myself enough and
all that it just feels about you know
like for example my grandmother she
never loved herself and now she's
suffering of dementia ligo
please have wanted one another to do
with each other I don't know because
like for example like my grandmother she
always said I love my husband I love my
kids and I love this but and I was when
I remember even like my brother asked
her like abuela do you love yourself
she's never answered but it just sounds
like that she's a higher level
though the highest almost love is when
you forget yourself
if you really Master love love is about
what you do for others it's not only
about yourself that's why what's what
power to do on on the money it's about
it's covert narcissism you're saying you
love yourself love self-love what you're
talking about is I'm all about me and me
is the most important when you really
understand love it's about others your
your abuela gave everything to our
family yeah right that's the highest
form of love you ask them what you need
she's like I don't even know I'm just
here for you guys
say dumb question yeah that was a dumb
question it's like what and you know
what else I've noticed that the women
that get the most from man give the most
yeah and they're never counted they're
Never Keeping score of what she like I
did all this like it's like a red flag
when I hear girls say oh I did this for
him I did this for him I did this for
him because that just means you're
keeping score and the women that are
genuinely motherly and are good in
relationships and like that men want to
be with they they give selflessly and
they don't ask for anything in return
but they end up getting more yeah and
you die for that woman yeah a man would
die for that woman should never know
should never know I never tell women
what did you say I feel like eventually
I feel like a good woman goes through so
much before she actually gets the goods
like you go through so many men while
like you're giving your all you're
giving yourself no a good woman good
woman good women get picked quick I mean
like they might take one come on they
might take one or two else yeah like
they might I'm not talking about five
six hours not usually like there's a
girl I knew in college and she was she
was honestly cute like she wasn't like
stunning but like she was she was cute
right but men were just like she got the
right morals it wasn't even she knows
she was just really feminine yeah um and
she was a Christian and like men were
lined up to date her because of the way
she made them feel she never had an
issue with men taking advantage of her
she never had an issue with men you know
um being in situationships like she got
the relationship easy because she was
kind she was loving and she was selfless
but like the women that always complain
about being taken advantage of usually
they're not doing something they're not
selfless I feel like selflessness yeah
because big things they're counting
there's also it's also the right values
you've also got to know how to pick the
right men and right now social media has
a lot of women confused thinking that
they need the guy with the most amount
of likes who wears the latest trainers
who has the biggest chain and you're
passing over decent guys and so that
that's that's why I'm saying again
you're being misled because your Youth
and your beauty right now your internet
right now is you're at your Peak this is
this is what you should really be
gunning for that guy this is the time
these God these older women are saying
oh yeah chill you know it's a journey
you know look at the woman who are
telling you that and and tell me if
they're successful women in happy
relationships that's all I'm saying but
I feel like like adding on to what
you're saying it's about also the
generation we're in today I feel like
that makes a big difference like females
RH for example then they might say
self-love because
life is different I feel like do you
guys I'm sorry go ahead but it's not
it's not the generation we're in today
it's the choices that women make today
yeah it's not it's not the generation
Society doesn't make you do things you
pick what percent of women are virgins
on their wedding night that's a choice
what would you say like you you
mentioned something just a second ago
when you were like oh um before it gets
something like women get take taken for
granted what's the point where you can
give be so selfless and you can keep
giving and giving and giving giving
where's that fine line between giving so
much and then just being absolutely
walked over yeah literally what do you
have to what what what what changes
what's the stopping point you know for
you like your personal opinion
um
I I think that people that are genuinely
selfless aren't asking what they get in
return and they tend to get more and
they don't tend to pick men that treat
them like [__] and even even the men
that are a little bit more of [__]
they
they usually act right for those girls
or like do more for those girls because
like I buy Landslide yes they'll do more
for that girl the difference between
this and and selflessness
if a man wants to act right he's gonna
act right if he's not acting right yeah
but but we go but we go like women we
always blame the men instead of
ourselves like like the question is if
the men aren't treating you right what
are you doing like what are you doing
and it's the same way when men when men
the women aren't treating them right
they have to say okay what am I doing
wrong Alex had to read how many books
five books on women
and study a text game to get the results
we wanted but it's like when women we're
not getting the relationship or we're
not getting men to treat us right we say
oh well to you well it's automatically
Bloom yeah but maybe maybe it's
something you're not doing yeah of
course I agree sorry did you no I was
just gonna say you know you guys are
talking about going on a journey I just
want to be very clear with you you are
at the top of your sexual Marketplace
value right now at that age a woman in
21 22 23 you were at the top of your
value so if you're really looking at it
like a Marketplace like Troy says I'd
sell like your top on Market you sell
you know and that should be the goal
um is to sell when you're when you're at
top
um obviously I will never be able to sit
here and tell you young ladies what it's
going to take for you to be happy that's
not for me to tell you I would tell you
that finding a strong man that you can
look up to and admire and want to get
behind is likely your best bet and at a
younger age and an older age and that's
all just going off that what you just
said sorry
um I just have a bit of like a just like
confusion in my brain because obviously
you said oh I'm not going to sit and
tell you like how much like what you
should do to be happy but you I
personally think you are quite
disrespectful to like Regina about like
what she does to who she said that she
loves her work and she loves her job and
I'm yeah she said she likes taking dick
for money yes I I don't know but that's
exactly what she that's exactly what she
said but like you don't her personally
You Don't Know Her circumstances like I
just think that was really disrespectful
what does that have to do with what I
just said though no but like you said oh
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
what I mean ask you a question
um when did you start doing sex work
um hold
I started doing it like back in lockdown
okay so like what two years ago
um three is it three now guys yeah
um do you do you regret that are you
happy with that decision I'm happy
okay how do you know that you're happy
I'm so sorry that to us about how do you
know like what is it that makes you know
that because uh even though like at the
end of the day I'm like oh yeah I'm
doing these and these and these like oh
people should think I am a SLA
if I don't have any regret
why has it affected your dating life at
all has it made it harder today
[Music]
yes or no yes and no I mean like um I
always find myself like
I never really wanted to have a
relationship
and I always end up into relationships
like without me wanting to
and as well like because in my world
it's really it's really difficult today
and I'm not talking about like the being
an escort world because
um I am a trans woman as well at the
same time boom told you told you but I
didn't say it wasn't true I just said
you didn't have to say [__] well she
was attacking she was packing what did
you say no she keeps coming at me and
like here's the thing I'm not coming if
you're happy I can't sit here and tell
you either this is if you're happy
you're happy yeah but like for example
like I agreed with a lot of things
you've done you've said right and I'm
honest but like now in front of people
and stuff like that I don't accept you
you're calling me [__] yeah that's
right no like we were getting after it
and that's fine but I I don't know
because I didn't call you I can't I
didn't did I feel free
to do it I mean never do it because I
respect you as a person at the same time
I respect you are coming no I just
didn't I didn't no and so what and I'd
like well first of all if I've offended
you I'm sorry yeah no I feel offended so
do I because you asked me a bunch of
[__] to piss me off and whatever but
what I'm what I'm saying to these ladies
is completely different than your
situation why why tell me because
they're substantially younger and
they're not in the same business yeah
they're not going to be in the same
business and they want a different
probably want a different situation in
their life well that's why that's why
I'm not imposing myself on to them
am I and that's fair but to answer your
question I said something to them she
diverted to you instead of going with
what we were actually talking about
going to what you said though you said
about the journey I feel like we are
quite me personally I've always wanted
to get married from a younger age
I didn't want to be 21 and not married
yeah me too literally but I feel like I
don't know maybe Journey for you is
different but for me I wanna I'm not
saying I wanna go all the way to 35 and
still be single right it's more about me
knowing that I'm ready to be a wife
because I my mother my mom is a married
woman my father
and their relationship is good I would
like I look for that but I'm not going
to rush into that and just think oh I'm
21 I need to get married and I
completely agree with you so that's what
I think I'm just talking to you yeah and
that's fine call It Journey whatever
I'm just simply saying that you're very
much more likely to find yourself in a
happy place if you don't go sleep with
like tons and tons and tons of men and
that you don't wait until you know
you're past your 30s in order to get
married no no I agree with you I've seen
it from a place to try to like like be
disrespectful to you guys I'm just
simply saying it's very likely that it's
the case
yeah it's it yeah life is it is
I agree to them to a certain extent I'm
not gonna sit here and just say like
listen to oh yeah man can cheat and can
do this man could do that cool if you
want to cheat if you want to do that
then you can go do that in your own but
my man and that's completely okay I
could do that so I knew we're talking
about the large majority so that's what
I'm talking about in my personal opinion
I don't want no man that cheats I don't
want no sneaky man I want an honest man
because if I decide as my personal
choice that I have a man that's my
husband and he's sleeping with someone
else and I accept that for myself and he
can do that on the side then that's my
personal issue that's literally to do
with me and my boyfriend but I thousand
percent agree with you I don't do as you
wish a woman accepts that and they want
that in their life like I know a woman
or a girl that she's with a boy
he constantly cheats on her he tells her
life oh this is what's happening I'm
cheating on you I'm with these other
women and she accepts it so at the end
of the day she can't sit and chat [__]
or anything about it because she accepts
that lifestyle I think he's absolutely
fine for you to have whatever
aspirations
for your life it's just that it's just
that you've also got to recognize the
the reality the work is on the wider one
like being a realistic person and living
in delusion because you're looking for
you're sort of looking for a bit of a
unicorn in a way aren't you if you're
looking for a unicorn you're looking for
a I assume a very high value guy yeah
but also at the end of the day but you
also never like cap it because imagine
like I meet someone in two days I
completely fall in love with them yeah
and I'm okay with them doing that you
can never put a cap to anything but at
the end of the day my morals right now
that's what you want to cheat somebody I
don't want no man that talks to any
other girl so to clarify your your
answer to the question
is that yes I would leave personally but
at the end of the day you can't really
cap it at anything because imagine
you're completely in love with the man
exactly what about what about you yeah I
agree with you like right now you're
saying you're laughing it like that yeah
yeah but when you're actually in the
situation like it's completely different
to what you want and you're I suppose
okay you should leave her stay give me
one I would say leave leave it go bye
what about you leave her son
um depending on the situation State yeah
depending on the situation okay I need
more respect
[Music]
so question I want to know does it does
it switch if you have children your
answer
yeah I think when you have children it's
way different a lot of people stay in
relationships sometimes because of their
kids but in some people on the other
hand they'll think we can both look
after the kids just not while we're
together because if you can go and cheat
on me no I'm asking you so not not with
someone else
all right all right who's who's staying
if there's kids raise your hand I'm not
staying just for the kids
okay so you were you were not raised to
be a wife if you're gonna put yourself
before your kids
it depends on the situation no you just
it depends on the situation how am I
going to have a conversation if I can't
believe the words that you say no you
can ask me a question it just depends it
really depends on the situation so this
is the situation go on tell me your
situation the footballer the footballer
footballer He Cheats
he pays for everything
you got you got you got two two Little
Rascals running around I'm not gonna lie
at the end of the day that's what any
girl would say
damn near not any damn any God would
stay but I didn't date my personal uh
yeah my person believes I would say no
okay so he would leave so that goes to
my question how are you raised to be a
wife it's nothing to put in it really it
really is do you believe you're a
traditional wife
to a certain extent I was raised on
those beliefs but like I feel like
because I grew up in the Western World
in London
slightly changed so it's it's
traditional entirely modern and that but
that mindset is modern because
traditional societies
um basically I'm trying to find the
definition what's the difference between
traditional and modern um traditional
Society is characterized by Community
ownership where Modern is individual
it's okay traditional
is the family first modern is me first
like that's the difference a tradition I
was raised on always pitting my family
first so I could never see if I was in
that position no no then maybe I was
there before
I'm begging you I'm a straight answer
please I don't feel like I would
personally okay maybe if I was putting
this no just to show you this is the
hypothetical situation you said you'd
leave before yeah okay if it's a
cheating thing then okay but that's what
I'm saying like myself before that it's
not self-respect being raised as a wife
I feel like that also comes with not
being cheated on so that's why that's
what I feel like it's a very wrong but
the figures you don't really you don't
marry into it
her grandma or you say grandpa your
grandmother grandmother had a whole
family across town like I mean the same
time
how many of our grandmothers and
great-grandmothers and
great-great-grandmothers show up to
their husband's funeral and meet their
families too
8 000 years ago 17 men reproduced for
every or 17 women reproduced for every
one man I'm really intriguing if you're
in like a married household like more
time the parents are not gonna wanna
show you if they're like cheating
because they want you to have like a
good image of marriage and they want to
be the role models so they're not going
to show you the ins and outs of their
relationship and like what goes back
because they want you to have this
um this is what a relationship looks
like so I feel like when kids are
involved like and he's doing everything
that he's meant to do as a man he's
providing he's protecting he's being a
father to the children he's got time for
me we're going on like we're doing stuff
as a family we're actually a family unit
I feel like yeah I probably would stay
because it's like it's not like it's
coming out of our marriage or it's like
he's stepping out of his role that's
when you know I feel like I would leave
because it's like what I'm actually with
you for I'm being a wife you're not
being a husband that's that's a good
development I think I think in
traditional societies when you look at
relationships say in Nigeria in the
village one of marriages people having
married problems they don't come out to
the woman and say
how do you feel every day is he okay is
he treat you well they normally say is
he is he making money are you fed do you
have a house is he doing his freaking
job
I've noticed in the west it's kind of
how you feel it's like you know in
certain situations that I think yeah be
cautious of that that if a man has a
role to protect to provide to be a
certain kind of pillar don't mix that up
with you know an egotistical battle to
be the girl who kind of you know the it
girl who doesn't get cheated on who gets
everything She Wants who gets the
millionaire footballer and and the
monogamy under nice bags under constant
attention and feels good every day all
the time and I'm not even saying that
every guy's gonna cheat but it's like we
pick the men that are gonna and then get
shocked when it's just like what about
you anyways I'm gonna Read Super chats
um I'm sorry guys I really appreciate
all the super chats we're trying to save
um okay we want to do
um as you saw we had a recent vlog where
we went up and down the stairs 21 floors
here yep yep can you be impressed
because
uh where as a team we had to run up and
run down
um I'm not gonna say who won but it was
me
hey you do you need to do it with us
okay you you okay okay King probably
would have won but he didn't do it with
us now what we'd like to get is some
cameras that we can put here and so
everyone can you can live stream with us
while we're racing
anyways
um so super chats so any super chats
that's what I don't know what those
cameras are called but that's what we're
trying to get 90 90 free what'd you say
oh we're trying to get GoPros yeah
90 free-toe pie I'm Pearl if you want an
answer from an honest answer from women
ask the question to start and stay
silent waiting for them to answer what
you asked watch them squirm Edgar Ray is
um she has a large tattoo that says it
all um Sean whatever the occupation
anybody with half a brain knows fast
money is slow problems only short-term
happiness and family is long-term it
only depends if that individual has the
guts to admit it um
uh a bands one um if I have to make 200k
a year what are you bringing to the
table for me to get that series about
you cooking and cleaning that's cool but
I'd rather procreate with a smart
athletic and empathetic woman not a
drone Doug MPA on the sex worker has
been disrespectful disrespectful to
Justin the whole time how he's been how
he's been acting has been completely
uncalled for we've seen it all show 93
topi women always tell the truth in that
moment based on their feelings I'm happy
selling my body now I'm happy with only
fans now Frenchie Blondie has been
sending digs to Justin all night and he
responds and she's offended ladies on
the couch need to stop defending her
she's wrong
um Francisco I plead that all the girls
here look into
um all the men's and Pearls advice ask
yourself when will be the next time
y'all are getting advice like this other
men let me hit it and quit it
um wine silk um Mary gave birth to Jesus
at 12 to 14 35 is Granny age geriatric
pregnancy your dad should have
um
given you to your husbands and your
teams you've been misled I'm vinery the
skills that men look for in a wife are
skills to be a good mother if you can
take care of your man and then you can
take care of your kids if you can only
care for yourself how are you showing
your good motherly skills sorosloot
single women keep other women single
Jack Frost Pearl has a glow not sure if
it's the lights got upgraded or she got
pregnant what rude
lyrically inclined women with British
accents sound really smart saying a lot
of dumb-ish
biology will be against you at 35 Plus
you are getting old it's that simple
stop getting triggered um today UK
that's why Uptown is fixing men zero oh
Father black Moses it's clear that
outside of sex modern women have nothing
to offer other than drama and disrespect
Dion C only wifey on the panel is Pearl
the rest of mental de rephrases single
season meaning catching bodies d uh
single season is catching bodies stop
capping Doug MP and women have nothing
to offer but sex to a man now they want
men to achieve and become his best self
but then have to come home and beg for
sex um they want the power over a man
these days are those days are over
ladies a mini f
ever heard of tick tock brain that makes
you dumber D if you let them talk they
tell on themselves um you're slick um if
the women are 20 and jaded at three or
the women are 20 and jaded 304s 20 is
too late
um johnster small many Rolo miss being
regurgitated tonight they're mostly
unproven like alpha fox Smith look at
the research behind it mostly it's poor
quality um Zoro slot modern women are
walking contradictions Deonte most men
who will treat a girl right are um the
stuff she wants and most likely not in
the friend zone or not your type
um
your our volunteer sex workers called
girlfriends
um Doug MPA please tell women the women
the candy store analogy um d uh 304s
depend on Instagram like it's oxygen a
woman's a girl's trip is an excuse to
make thirsty photos open your Instagram
304 Behavior not a wife Frenchie a
thousand likes and they'll open up the
chat let's go guys
um Zoro slot if the world doesn't owe
you understanding men are as faithful as
their options it's a choice to stay with
that type of man um shout out to Jay
Waller
um Edgar Ray's ladies just accept it's a
double standard I'm at the end of the
day he comes back to you and the kids
Edgar tontilla is part of South America
I'm going to refresh it really quick
guys if you send super chats I will read
them I'm only going to read the ones
over um ten dollars the rest of the show
just to save time
um
um Sean keep on fighting Pearl um 90
free taupe hi I'm are not
um a Brands F1 pearly is being smart
well-read um intuitive traditional
Modern Art neutral okay
um do you know the Justin do you know
the candy store analogy can you tell us
yeah I've heard say it before
um so basically the way I've heard him
explain it I've never used it but
a man starts his life off at the bottom
of a mountain and he fights his ass off
and he gets hit by rocks and he gets
torn up and his ass handed to him and he
gets beat up and he falls down the
mountain has to start over goes bankrupt
he finally fights and fights and fights
and Claws away and he gets to the top of
the mountain and he gets into the candy
shop and he eats his first piece of
candy and they tell him that's the only
piece he can have
and generally a man that's done all of
that work is going to be like [__] you
I'm gonna take over the whole store
because very very very few men will ever
get up that mountain it's called the one
percent for a reason and it is a [__]
dog fight
and that's what he's referring to it's
the thing that drives him in now there's
a lot of men out there that'll say oh
that's [__] no using it as a dating
strategy any man
that could
love his wife tuck his kids in at night
be a good man provide for his entire
family be there as a father be a
provider be the hero for his family and
sleep with a couple women every now and
then would do it and anybody that says
otherwise is a [__] liar
straight up
and and look I know that sucks and it's
not fair and it's completely not fair
but it is the reality of the world and I
think sometimes when we talk about these
subjects we get lost between the
realities of the world and the Motions
because I know it I know it hurts it
does but it is absolutely true
wow
what do you guys think of that
silence every test at an extent oh no
not to a certain extent speaking to the
mic
their silence agrees with me they don't
have silence agrees that's what I was
going to say yeah their silence agrees
with me and look man I'm sorry
yeah and I get it
like I said before if I could pay a
million dollars to cut it off
I actually would I would absolutely cut
it off I think it's a waste of time
it will haunt a man it is in us just in
US
oh yeah it is it's an assault it's in
every one of us it's just it's just the
fact that a lot of men don't want to
climb that mountain yeah and so they'll
trade off things that they don't
actually want to do to get some piece of
candy
but the men that really want to hustle
want the whole [__] store and
generally that's the man that you're
going to admire and look up to because
he has ambition he has Drive in his life
he's a hard worker you believe in him
and most of all you trust him to take
care of you yeah that's all I'm saying
and I don't mean to be disrespectful but
I genuinely want you to hear me because
I fear that if young women that are
young and beautiful like you girls are
are taking advice from older women that
are not happy you are going to find
yourself in that same position I'm
saying it look as as heated as it got
I'm saying this out of love not not to
put you down I genuinely believe it
and I'm also not manipulating you
because I'm not trying to get with any
of you I'm going to get on a plane in a
couple days you know what I'm saying but
please let me leave this with you or
watch it again
any man that could would
I often say I'm not doing anything that
any other man would not do if he could
all right I love you all
I'm curious did any of you change your
opinion on cheating after listening to
him or after having this conversation
tonight I hate that it's called cheating
in the first place I hate that school
she is because because the cheating is a
triggering part you know like if he set
you down
like like pretty teeth said
you know she's like I wouldn't like it
but I would appreciate the truth yeah
it's the deceit that really is gonna
upset you because he's killing himself
for you he loves you more than anything
you take a bullet for you and the slags
on the side dude he don't even want him
in his bed at night
he's in love with you
yeah because it's you know how you guys
get emotional for no reason men are like
yeah so are you saying it's just like an
ego stroke
the point it's not about ego at all it's
not about ego at all like men that sleep
with women just to feel better about
themselves are super insecure yeah
they're lacking something right they're
lacking something no no it is more like
it's more like this primal thing inside
of you that will not get out of your
[__] head so is it Primal or is it
lacking something no no it's Primal it's
completely Primal does the fact that 8
000 years ago 17 women reproduced for
every one man does that mean anything to
you does that show at all that it's
primal
that always in history there's always
been more women reproducing for men I
think historically yeah but like so if
I'm trying we try and adapt like where
humans were you know creatures of
adaptation like I would try my best to
adapt if I didn't if something didn't
sit sit right with me but okay so so if
in modern society we're going back to
that like we're trending more towards
sharing men
I don't even like to share my food so
best move I'm not sure
you're wrong you're wrong you have again
because we spoke about you've been in
situationships so you were sharing a guy
you're sharing guys right now but we're
beating a dead horse right you're all
sharing guys right now I'm not sharing a
new one yeah well we keep coming back to
the same we keep coming back to the same
point because you guys whenever whenever
Justin whenever Justin makes the or
somebody makes the point and says well
no Matt this is how men are white this
is how they're programmed these are the
things that they want then somebody on
the couch or wherever says um oh but not
all of them like like you did and it's
kind of like but no but we keep we keep
beating the same horse they they do all
want to do it they or they they are all
programs not all of them necessarily
will act on it but that's partly down to
okay there's gonna be a few unicorns who
aren't going to act on it because
they're super amazing whatever guys but
I think so repercussions are scared yeah
yeah probably yes but for the most part
for the most part they're not going to
act on it because then they don't have
the ability to because they're not high
enough in the food chain okay the guys
are at the top they all are going to act
on it and that's just how it is it's
also character as well right yeah I know
you think sorry go on it's also a
character like I think I can personally
relate because at some point you have a
connection that's distinct enough with
someone that it takes a long time for
that urge to come back yeah she'll come
back though sure oh yeah about at about
18 months probably yeah I'm not gonna
lie even for me I'll be like you know
what I could like really Vibe with
someone like she's one in a million
she's got chat we're cool but I part of
me knows that in like in like a year
maybe two some people been together for
20 years I know eventually
two becomes one why don't you think like
that but I I know I'm like that that's
one of the reasons I didn't have
relation when I was younger because I
thought I don't want to do that I don't
mess someone up but I realize bro I'm
always it's just human nature it's
novelty yeah I've tried to fix myself in
my 20s I thought something was wrong
with me and I thought I was all [__]
up and I hated myself for a long time
yeah I broke up with Miss Louisiana in
college because I like I felt like I
couldn't do it and I didn't want to be a
piece of [__] and I wouldn't try to pray
about it and do all this church stuff
and I couldn't defined it was just a
pattern that would not leave me in and I
was I was leaving women that I loved was
that because there's something to do
with like yourself no not at all it was
literally what I'm telling you I
wouldn't lie to you and let me let me
nail it home with this
it could be an ugly woman
ugly woman I could eat for me it's
hungry and horny to a man it's pretty
much the same thing I gotta stress this
to you no do you know what I do agree
with that like I do agree that it's
nothing to do with the looks it doesn't
matter is she I don't bro does it
breathe like men are disgusting that is
the first thing that I actually 100 like
agree with you on it she could be the
ugliest girl in the world
but the old thing it's like it's like
the old thing you know you've got steak
at home but sometimes you just fancy
going out for a McDonald's you know what
I mean and that's just the reality yeah
it's not even about cheap it's just
about different and it's like this thing
is people people demonize it and act
like you know was this more bro it is
wired into US it almost comes out of us
in a way and and again I cannot stress
this enough if I could pay to get rid of
that feeling I would absolutely do it
100 I guess it's nice it's not nice
that's the wrong word but I guess it's
like
a bit more a better feeling for us girls
to know that he's sat there saying that
if he could get rid of it he would do
you know what I mean it's
counterproductive yeah
know what I mean it's like if you're
saying that you could I'd get rid of
this if I would pay to get rid of it yes
see that's reassurance for us girls but
you don't probably think that you're
reassuring is saying that that's just
something that you personally believe
what John was saying for us girls that
is reassurance
wants to do that I don't know I think
modern women don't really hear these
things though I think it's hard for us
there's not many men that can say it and
get away with it there's no spaces to be
honest yeah I think Pearly things is a
safe space in some ways right
but it's not but it's not but let me
tell you something else about you guys I
have a platform right women see my
content women women that I see will see
me say this and they'll see me anyway
you understand what I'm saying like I'm
not of course I'm not trying to bully
y'all like I have this like many many
many men cannot say what I'm saying and
get away oh yeah and so
I know you're not used to hearing it and
and for that reason I'm trying to be
graceful right now because I feel like
earlier it got heated but truly if I
could get rid of it yeah if I could get
rid of it I truly mean it up here
for the ladies um what questions do you
guys have for men that you don't
understand about men
[Music]
I think I think my like confusion is
what does the the mind that you know
that fights through all these battles
and gets to the candy store and tries to
take it what does that look like in
today's world that's what's I think
that's a problem with um with us young
younger women I don't know it's not it's
not like back in the day where it was
clear we live in a different world you
know the social media it confuses us you
know so we're just like what we the
words like rappers and footballers and
um you know Drake get thrown into these
conversations and it's like oh yeah
that's what a high value man is but it's
like an accurate question it's like what
is what does that guy look like in
today's society or is it or is it the
same well she read it off but I don't
think you have to be Drake to be high
value as I said I don't like I don't
like the word
you know I don't like the alpha the beta
the high value I don't like any of those
things but I think a man that completely
takes care of business and can give you
a life that you'd have never had
otherwise and he can be the hero to you
and he takes pride in that not in
um not by belittling you but by loving
you and empowering you to level up to
where he's trying to go so you can be on
his arm when he's at that event yeah
that's the right way you know what I'm
saying
it's not it's not about belittling it's
about building up and that's why I asked
you the question I asked you earlier
yes ma'am I know yeah and but when you
have a real man in front of you yeah he
wants to build you up that's how you
can't even say that people are high
value men until you actually like that
like Drake to be honest you've never
really I've never really seen him with
like a proper light in a proper like
relationship right and that's a place
and that's a placeholder situation now
we'll say that it's probably smart to
protect the queen
in that regard yeah if Drake is smart
he'll never let you see her yeah yeah
that makes sense of course but hopefully
if that woman exists he's building her
up he's almost doing everything he can
to put every amount of knowledge in her
so she's qualified to be with him and he
understood yeah listen baby you gotta
you gotta dress like you can talk like
this when they do this do this start
with the forks here like he loves her
he's I pick you so I develop you and I
protect you from the world like I'm here
to protect you from it's me and you and
I've got you and the thing I think why
it's so hard for like women to like
understand that is because that now is
seen as so toxic and it's like anyone
that acts like that it's all your toxic
man or it's coming from insecurities we
are living an upside down world and even
if we do go back to the Bible yeah like
kings they did have um
and not just multiple wires but they
also had um what's it called concubines
and it kind of makes sense that these
people were so loved by God and it's
like adultery it kind of makes sense for
you to say cheating is when you're
deceitful but what is what is what is
toxic masculinity anyway it's just a
couple of words it's just a buzzword
that somebody's made up and it now gets
applied to all manner of things that
just because somebody doesn't like it
it's an easy way to attack a weak man
and get him to shut up yeah I've heard a
lot of a lot of feminists say that
they've they subconsciously associate
masculinity with negativity that's where
it comes from that they they
subconsciously don't like men
and they act they acted out they don't
know who they are it's true it's like
even when they say um he needs to open
up more and be more emotionally
available you're teaching a man to be a
woman men don't men don't um talk about
their problems the same way that women
do they want to bring them down and
they're and they're automatically
assuming that the like the female wit
like the female way is the right way and
so yeah and so like they're saying the
the male way of dealing with problems
like getting being like aggressive
getting into a fight
um not talking about them that's wrong
but the female way of talking about our
problems is right yeah and it's like
we're brainwashing men and trying to
turn them into women
they will tell you that as well and
they're learning that in school as well
I went out with someone I think I I
mentioned that I was reassessing the way
I approached some relationships in an
effort to provide more value to people
who cared about me because I can be too
introverted sometimes and her immediate
response was oh someone's growing up
this is a grown woman and I she wants to
apologize for it proficially after but I
I noticed these things I was like that's
what you really think right you think oh
I get therapy if you really listen to
them how they think when they say I want
to be his mother I have to act like his
mother it's it's there guys if you
listen long enough it's there but to
answer your question as to what uh
respectful man is I would say
I I am somewhat respectable so I want to
give my opinion in dance I noticed that
a lot of the women go for the teachers
who are very overtly sexual and who know
how to press their buttons they know
exactly how to say things how to create
the drama the women like and only after
they've been with that guy do they then
realize oh I want to have like a more
someone who's actually going to commit
to me as well as being a sexy dance
teacher so they get with some loser who
does a lot of work who talks to everyone
who's not particularly attractive and
then that doesn't work out then they
come to me and be like okay you've got
all those qualities but now you've
already disqualified yourself yeah you
know because I spoke to you a while ago
I normally do this I talk to women I ask
them out I'm not I'm not the best I
don't say like particularly witty things
or interesting things I do that on
purpose because I don't think I have to
be witty to spend time with someone to
get to know someone I think the effort
in itself is valuable so I let them
filter me out knowing that yeah you're
gonna get with Pedro and Juan and then
it's gonna be Tim and David and then
you're gonna be back here winking at me
every Saturday and you know and it's a
shame they have to learn through
experience but it's literally a cycle
dance also learn to dance you will you
will see the line you learn so quickly
so value those qualities value the guy
who comes in he's playing by example but
value the man who have values value the
men who aren't chasing I know it's it's
easy to pick the guy who's constantly
chasing you he's texting every day he's
he's doing the most but that doesn't
necessarily mean it's valuable that
doesn't necessarily mean he likes you
you could just be horny but I feel like
a high value man a woman will want a
woman want him without him doing
anything yes I agree like I feel like I
feel like you like to absorb women like
yeah like I feel like women is so sad to
say but you like the guy that actually
does nothing like my brother he's
someone he told me that he's very good
looking my brother yeah he used to do
modeling and stuff and he told me he's
never spoken that he's never like gone
to speak to a girl before like a girl
has always just come to him and I was
like what like are you serious and was
like yeah but it's like I don't know if
he's gonna find his wife that way but I
don't think he's looking for wife right
now but it's like the woman will always
come to you if you're just you just
Attract it well I think generally in
human nature we want the things that we
can't quite get you know yeah you can't
quite grab hold of but it seems to be
particularly cute in women as far as
dating is concerned you know they won
that guy they think they can't quite get
him they can't quite get hold of him you
know maybe he's too and it's the
hypergamy thing isn't it you know it's
it's easy a little bit too high value
for me is he slightly out of my reach
those are the guys that they tend to
want or they or you tend to want on a
visceral sort of level he loves me loves
me not hmm
what what what do you want to know about
men me yeah what questions do you have
uh I might have to have a little think
you know yeah I'll pass it on to double
it and pass it on to the next person
um I don't really have anything I want
to learn about men particularly
to be honest I don't have like any
actual questions you were brought up in
Brazil were you you were born in Brazil
so I was born in America then I moved to
Brazil right okay because obviously the
society there is a lot more traditional
than here right so you see a lot of
differences with the when you're here
like my family is like an extremely
traditional family like my parents
expect me to get married in the next few
years yeah your wife my mom's like
growing up my mum would make like jokes
like oh like see it I would eat
something and leave the wrap on the
table she'd be like oh your husband's
gonna send you back if you continue this
Behavior just like little things like
that you know I have a question and
don't don't take offense to this how
does your mom like the tattoos and the
nose ring and the crop tops because you
see like you say you're raised to be a
wife and you're like more of a
traditional woman you very well might be
but the way that you present yourself to
the world
and so it's like how if a guy was to
approach you yeah is he gonna approach
you like a wife or is he going to
approach you like like a side check well
yeah obviously I have guys approaching
me every single type of way but once
once people know what I'm on and know
how I am then they'll approach me the
way like I want to yeah but but we start
with looks right so if you're walking
down the street this is the way I choose
to look obviously I'm gonna attract the
different like a different reaction than
I originally won right but I but I ask
I'm just wondering why like why why live
on hard mode I don't really live on hot
mood this is just the way I choose
no I mean because you're beautiful so
I'm sure you I'm sure you get approached
regardless
but I just I just wonder like why if you
were raised to be like traditional it's
like I can't what you mean because even
when I started wearing the crop tops
when I started getting the tattoos trust
me my parents did not speak to me when I
started getting the tattoos they didn't
like they're all asking me why are you
dressing this way if you were raised in
a very Christian household but it's just
the way I choose to present action
against I don't really think it's a
reaction against it's just my personal
style because I wear a crop top but then
I'll wear like something under my legs
it's not like I'm showing my whole body
or I'm acting provocative or I'm acting
in a certain way with men like maybe I'm
that one example that maybe you can
present yourself in one way and be
completely the other because as you say
we speak about the huge majority but
it's not every single person that's
going to be like that I don't remember
if you said earlier do you want to be
married in the next couple years married
in the next couple years so wouldn't it
make sense to present yourself like a
wife yeah of course okay so like yeah so
can we take out the notes ring I'll be
so happy
she got two in her tongue one in her
belly you have a tongue ring too she's
got two
you like it you like it yeah I feel like
that determines the type of person I am
because if any of you took just 10
minutes out of your day to sit down no
you're very sweet I've spoken to you all
for sure yeah but it's it's more the way
I present myself I agree I compete I'm
not saying anything against like the way
I look the way I present myself I
completely agree the tattoos the
piercings the crop top it does say
something yeah I'm just saying it just
doesn't no the reason I'm saying this is
because I want you to win yeah like I
want you to win in life yeah and and
it's like you know as as nice as it is
for for people to say oh where would you
want do like do what you want it's like
it's not going to help you get the
outcomes you seem to want
um it could to be honest I've come
across a lot of different people in my
life I've present myself in this way but
I get a lot of different reactions like
it's all about how you are as a person
like this is all about appearance
that's wrong because men judge you on
the way you look yeah men judge yourself
but then when they actually take that
extra step but they're not going to take
the extra step to see how you are
because they already put you in a box
and what they're gonna think is this hey
if I if I make her my wife if I if she's
my girlfriend she's gonna dress like oh
yeah like this and this is going to
represent I'm not saying anything
against it like I agree men will think
that if I just certain way but that's
just not the way I am personally but
like surely if a guy came to you and
said like like first glance and didn't
give you the time of day just because of
your tattoos and the crop top and the
nose ring and whatever
your your emotionally intelligent enough
to clock onto that and be like okay well
you're not the type of guy that oh yeah
that you would want anything you would
have put me in a box like that
I actually put
to put skin I'm not that type of like
cool maybe you can think all sorts of
crazy things trust me I get all sorts of
crazy reactions of the type of tattoos
I've have with the types of dress like
the um the way I dress do you do you
judge men based on how they dress like
if a guy is dressed like a homeless of
course as a first appearance okay so
that's why I'm not saying anything
against it right right so so I'm saying
like you started shaming man for judging
her okay no no no not you you and you
were saying that oh well that's not the
type of man I would want anyways but how
do you know that because if you saw a
guy that was homeless that looked
homeless even even though he wasn't you
might disqualify him based on everyone
disqualifies everyone based on looks not
not shaming men as such but I'm just
saying like for her like I I'd hope that
she was emotionally intelligent enough
to be like okay well if you're gonna put
me in that box I have the equal right to
then say Okay then if you're gonna put
me in a box like that I can equally put
you in a box and move on with my life
you're taking a defense stance and I
think it's more about kind of being
conscious and aware of of things I think
I think the difference is is like is
unnecessary you don't have to defend
yourself spiritually I think you just
have to be more conscious that like
those high level guys will notice the
tattoos like I don't care personally but
some guys will yeah you've got to just
accept that like I would say maybe if I
wanted to date like Bill Gates son or
like you know some Aristocrat from
France maybe he won't be into that yeah
and unfortunately because you're
beautiful he'll probably lie to you
thank you I just lost my Chain of
Thought yeah that's beautiful like
I don't really judge people really like
I know people would 100 think things of
me just because just purely Based On My
Tattoos just on that fact alone but I
never let that really play into my mind
like I have a very realistic mindset
well I would just say if you if you do
want to be married or you do want a
long-term relationship then I would
dress like someone that wants to be in
one yeah but I'm married right now bro I
don't need anyone to like guide the way
I just right now but obviously if I'm
married if I have a man no no I'm not
gonna be you said you wanted to get
married in the next couple years a
couple years yeah a few years more
likely a few years than a couple okay
okay maybe you need to add into that one
percent though like if you want to get
married to somebody from that one
percent no it's not no I'm sorry no it's
just
um no men across the board judge women
with tattoos yeah
you know if we're going to say a balance
of probability like there's exceptions
but we're going to talk about across the
board the menu like I'm from a pretty
well-off community and like most of my
brothers make six figures
um most people in our circles make six
figures and I can tell you that they
they absolutely judge you if you have
tattoos they absolutely judge you if you
have piercings and I didn't always like
this and I was younger I was like Mom
you're so judgmental why like I was so
mad that she wouldn't let me like do
this stuff and then the older I get the
more I see that she's right and I just
you know I really you know if if I can
encourage you in a different direction
that's probably what I'm gonna do it's
not to be on an end all though not at
all I think I think you could actually
end up making it something that works
for you you can a classy woman with
tattoo does stuff some Intrigue that
could be interesting so I'm not we're
not giving you like some kind of final
judgment yeah it's not a death sentence
at all yeah just just get a couple of
sun drops
I personally don't have a thing against
tattoo but I'm not gonna lie if I saw
someone with tattoos it doesn't scream
take me out to dinner talk to me every
night treat me like wifey It kind of
screams like you've probably had two or
few toxic relationships like you know
yeah that's my first impression it's not
you're on the journey yeah yeah
but for real girls I would say look at I
do agree with feminists on one thing in
that you you go you women have a lot
against you now more than ever and that
you have the worst role models ever like
when I look at modern women there's very
few role models and I always get the
impression when I speak to when I see
the women others look look up to other
women look up to I just like you're
looking after people who don't have what
you want you're looking up to women who
are coping with their bad decisions 34
year olds 32 year olds who are still in
the club who are trying to sell you on
this whole culture and accept yourself
and spirituality and they're not they're
missing out the little bit where it says
I messed up I missed the boat I had all
these opportunities at Uni I had all
these opportunities I messed up and I'm
still in this club with 21 year olds
trying to pretend that I've got it all I
guarantee you these women if they found
a decent guy they would fight you two to
know for that guy so just just remember
that not everyone wants the best feeling
that's what this all all women not every
woman wants the best for you either
misery loves company agreed yeah they
will lie to your face straight straight
straight straight up like devil doesn't
break into empty houses does it and
you're young you're young you know
they're gonna lie to you take your time
it's chill it doesn't matter you know
accept yourself you know you've got you
got time trust me after uni the amount
of high quality guys you meet on the
dating scene would reach you
significantly in uni you're in a pool of
just young people who are quite focused
and going towards somewhere when you
come out you on Tinder right and Tinder
anyone could be on tender anyone could
be on hinge people are trying to mess
around people broke it's long and and
the more time kind of passes the less
high quality men there are because men
figure out and just pick one and bounce
the guys you see every day are the guys
that are running through girls in it
does
and let's go back to the market thing
that Troy said the longer a house sits
on the market the more likely that house
is to drop in price yeah it decreases in
value right but I hate the whole you
just mentioned like Tinder and all this
stuff like when you go you need that
like and you dropped the word market as
well I don't like the whole idea that
women are
the whole thing is a market it's not
just women it's just everybody 100 but
for me personally like maybe call me
delusional call me naive but I just hate
the whole the whole hookup culture idea
that is so normalized today that don't
sit right on my conscience what who's
fault whose fault is hookup culture it's
the women's fault I think it's I think
it's the problem on both sides I don't
know what percent what percent of men
can partake in hookup culture what
percent of men get laid
I don't know the statistics or the facts
but I don't think it's a certain sex to
blame I think it's a problem I'm shared
on both sides we don't help each other
as women and I don't think men help
themselves either women want to sleep
with roughly 20 of men 20 of men and
some people would argue it's fewer but
we're going to say 20 of men are
sleeping with all the women
where 80 of women are sleeping with 20
of men so whose fault is hookup culture
um
is it more women doing it or more men
doing it I think you have the advantage
in this s like situation because
obviously you know the statistics like
I'm not stuck behind a company I don't
know the statistics like but I just from
my personal opinion and what I see is
that I wouldn't blame it on a certain
sex and I'll hold my hands up and say
that yeah but it's not the five foot two
nerdy guys who are causing hookup
culture is it you know what I mean I
think the point the point Pearl's making
is that you've got women who you know by
and large can can get access to sex
pretty easily for the most part not not
exclusive for the most part and then
you've got a certain a much smaller
sector of guys who are getting access to
that same sexually do you agree with the
saying women can
women sleep with who they want and Men
sleep with who they can yeah but that
but see that that's something you agree
with personally yeah 99 of yeah
but so that supports what I'm saying so
women are The Gatekeepers yeah because
women are in control of who who gets sex
so if there's a hookup culture when it's
women who are in control of hookup
culture if all women said tomorrow we
all said all right guys we're closing up
shop until we get around our fingers
everyone would be married I would buy
Zale stock
no but that's everyone the thing that's
everyone and we're not talking about
everyone we're talking the majority yeah
but that is that small percentage of
people that aren't like that we cannot
speak for everyone but we're talking in
generalities though okay but I'll Stand
to it for my personal opinion but that's
all I'm gonna say on that topic like I
don't think that will waver for me
personally
putting that on one specific sex like I
think we're both part to blame for
hookup culture but you don't think if
eight out of ten women are participating
it and one out of every 10 or maybe two
out of every 10 men are participating it
you don't think it's more on the women
because more women are doing it I didn't
I don't like I don't live by like
statistics and facts like I just I like
to search
[Laughter]
that's going to be a great clip
is Drake is Drake you want a Scottish
I've been trying to say this the whole
show
it was more responsible for hookup
culture the the Thousand women that have
slept with Drake or Drake
ha
men have the same thing right we all
want someone who doesn't have who hasn't
slept around but at the same time we've
also slept around a fair bit so I guess
I guess there's room on both sides You
could argue either Point that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah but you think Drake is
waiting for a virgin no nobody knows I
think his way I think I think most I
think most men expect that the girl has
I mean I don't know any guy that's
genuinely no no there's one that came on
my show yeah that was genuinely waiting
for a virgin but that's like one out of
what the hundreds of nine I've met all
year yeah
multiple girls come on the show and ask
for like we do the delusion calculator
20 30 of men
even even just physical characteristics
if you think of a guy you're attracted
to I think
Justin you're like six three
like two percent like two percent of men
are six three and then on top of that
being good looking and then on top of
that having a good job and then on top
of that being intelligent so I go and
dance with a lot of girls and salsa and
all these kind of scenes and they're
good looking they get all this attention
and they think I should be chasing them
you work in a bar Sarah
yep like we're not we're not the same
but a lot of them don't understand that
so just understand the Rarity like high
quality good things are not are not
frequent I know on Instagram it looks
like you have access to the hottest guys
and you get all these DMs like you think
yeah you know I can replace them to the
left to the left that kind of idea real
solid guys I have like four friends but
actually that rate is people like this
is a decent guy I have a lot of friends
who will sleep with anyone and lie and
do anything that the woman asks just to
get some ass and I know the difference
high quality men are rare
I agree
so I think your your next what questions
do you have for men
I should have been here thinking about
that
um
um because you've asked that most of
questions uh
Alex they're calling you a simp again ah
fair enough so be it
um I changed my answer every man is a
high value man
we all did I have the best
um what is a high value like what would
a high value man look for in the high
value woman unless I was already
answered oh you did ask that question we
didn't answer it did we
no I don't think I asked that question
oh okay good yeah
oh yeah
I didn't ask them well for the women not
for the menu okay that was a good
question me personally I like
um women who are focused on their goals
who are driven on something even if
that's being a mother I like women who
have like a purpose
um one of the most beautiful women I
ever messed up with was a French girl
she was doing cyber security very solid
um she was she was single for a period
after graduating and then she got with
the guy she was with the uni and now
she's got a daughter and she's a senior
cyber security consultant a leading
engineering firm I've I [__] up big
time I should have I should have been
hustling for that but I was like 19 to
21. so yeah women who are focused who
kind of are focused on their job women
who are
um supportive and who understand how to
like compliment a man I don't like
combative women
um I can deal with one but I'd rather
not
um and I'll say
women who are selfless like any of this
talk about like you know what I deserve
or I what I'm owed what the world owes
you extremely honest I I spoke to go on
hinge right and she was telling me how
all these Nigerian men in Manchester
wanted to wife her up and how like she
doesn't respect men unless they pay for
them pay for her food and stuff like
that that's a basic thing how can I
respect you if you don't even act like a
man this and that
um and I ignored everything she said and
asked her out because you know it was
just going to be some fun and she she
said oh you said link up and that means
that's disrespectful and he blocked me
this is like
this is this is the kind of
combativeness that kind of nature where
she felt the need to tell me how to
speak yeah on top of those ridiculous
demands I think that is a bit much like
but it's a lot of women though yeah yeah
I agree with the fact that a man should
pay for dinner though yeah of course but
I think the exchange is a man takes that
role and then she takes a feminine role
yeah yeah that's a real exchange so do
you know like don't ask for equality if
I'm gonna pay for everything
put a woman in her feminine energy
period but why is it
yeah to to put her in it why shouldn't
she be in it I think as a man if you're
not doing something in the relationship
that she needs or she is she she wants
from you she's gonna act in her
masculine energy
I actually kind of agree with this she's
gonna actually acting out yeah a little
bit because it's doing it it's his job
to take the role in the lead and that's
really why I was disagreeing with you so
hard on that being emotional nonsense
because if he comes home he's if you
translate what he's saying oh I got
problems in this and this he's saying I
can't take care of this I can't handle
it you should be scared because I am not
enough to handle the problems he should
come home and say I had a problem today
I absolutely took care of it you have
nothing to worry about yeah sleep like a
baby tonight I got this whole situation
I think when a man does that a woman has
no problem getting inside of a man a
really strong man's frame a masculine
man absolutely I have no problem see I
just find that girls that say that it's
just like they're just not feminine like
the most feminine what girls like that
say what like when they say when they
say um I I need a man to like put me in
my feminine energy
I think this I think there's two sides
to this I think on the one hand I think
you're right I agree with Justin I think
I think yeah a strong man is gonna put
you into your feminine and that's that's
absolutely correct however I also think
part of the problem is as I said women
are not approaching it from the point of
I should be in my femininity anywhere
also women in the western now again if
you go to South America or you go to
places in Eastern Europe and stuff like
that that aren't England and they aren't
America you get women who are much more
naturally in their they don't they don't
need to be told oh you know I'm going to
act up unless I'm putting my feminine
they're just going to do it naturally so
I think it's kind of a little bit of
both
I think when I think of like the most
feminine women I know like like when I
think of like the archetype of like the
what I would like hope to be one day
right
there's just no man that they could talk
to that would make them masculine
because they're just so so feminine I
think what you said about like culture
and stuff like I'm I'm part Jamaican so
like Jamaican women they are very very
tough like you don't cross a Jamaican
woman you know what I mean so maybe
that's like integrated in my system
trauma in Jamaican communities we've got
to learn from that and and that that is
passed on through I think culture does
make a big difference no but it is true
and with Jamaicans as well like I feel
like a lot of the time especially if
it's like single you have to be that
strong woman like I'm Jamaican you have
to be that strong woman
I don't yeah so a lot of the older
Generations they might have been
actually single and it's like they were
like that strong for like all their kids
like my grandma she had to be the single
woman I would call it trauma because
I've seen this cycle of single mothers
imparting all their horrible experiences
onto their kids and all this kind of
bullying and a lot of guys peaking at
high school and then using that to pray
on like 16 17 18 year old girls
basically bullying them with their
experience getting these girls pregnant
so I would say that's quite significant
I wouldn't say that's like normal mental
trauma like no you are actually
traumatized no you don't have to call it
traumatized because it's like you move
like you move on like I don't think it's
something
that is like what is trauma like trauma
is not a event it's how you take that I
don't think Truman's rule because it's
really and truly how you um
like what you take from that experience
perceive it you know I mean it's not
like oh I'm traumatized because this
happened you're traumatized because you
don't want to get over it or you don't
want to like better yourself to like get
over it there's levels obviously yeah
cool yeah could you finish of course
yeah what do you look for in a high
value woman I wasn't he was talking on
it I'm finished okay your turn
foreign
absolutely want what they would call
might call a high value woman what what
I think is very important to me is no
promiscuity
or very you know
um how you Market yourself online and
2023 is very important
the role that you allow the man to take
by empowering him to be the hero no man
doesn't want to be a hero to his family
that's what makes love such a beautiful
thing no man wants a woman he can't save
from a castle on a dragon not to say
that the woman is broken but he wants to
take the role of being appreciated for
taking care and putting everything on
the line for his family
is very very important to me and any
other man and I have no problem saying
that
in addition
one thing we've we've not really touched
a lot is beauty men truly care about
beauty and keeping yourself together you
know and being clean and and soft in the
way of a feminine woman and really
keeping up with that especially as you
start to get older I think it's really
important that you pay attention to that
because that's men judge other men based
off their girl
and it's very important to have a woman
that's not only beautiful and feminine
but it's also
willing to serve like in the feminine
role because it makes a man look good so
like let's say if you're at people come
over to your house or something like
that you you would ask his friends can I
get you guys anything like trying to be
trying to be like helping the group
because you respect the fact that they
might be talking about business not to
say that a woman can't do business I'm
just talking about a woman really being
in the feminine energy and even to a
degree submissive and I'm not sorry to
say it because really and truly no man
wants to date a person or be with a
person that he has to fight with to be
man of the house no of course no agreed
yeah agreed and you know what I think
for us females like that's so nice when
you can feel like you know you feel safe
let me defend you guys real quick this
is what's so hard for you guys
so much at risk for you to let go yeah
yeah there's so much at risk and I feel
like in this Western World especially
yeah and you hold on to it because you
don't know if this son of a [__] is
actually going to be able to do it yeah
and you're like [__] so it's a defense
mechanism yeah you're trying to defend
yourself and Men ain't [__] and I'm
gonna go on my journey because I'm going
to hold out and you know what sucks
about it a lot of times the girl's right
yeah [__]
but it premises that with the title of
the show right
what really truly sucks for women and
where I truly feel bad for you and where
I think your life is really really hard
you find the guy that can do it
and then he exercises options yeah but
what I would look for instead of that is
does he make you feel loved do you feel
safe will he sit down and have a heart
to heart did you you'll know if he
actually loved you or not yeah when you
get upset and you cry if he stops
everything he's doing cancels out and
he's with you truly
and he can look you in the eye and you
know he's there for you know he's going
to take care of it and you feel safe
around him safe enough to let go you
found the right guy yeah anything short
of that you're at a major risk because
you're risking it all and I understand
why a woman would want to hang on to a
little bit of her Freedom if he didn't
think he could handle it and that's why
I would never tell a man to cry to a
woman because you're telling her I can't
handle it which is going to make her
look elsewhere to find somebody who can
and that's just how it's always been and
that's how it is
what about you
um I think uh beauty is really important
like like you said I think I think that
is a key thing without wanting to sound
shallow but it's not shallow it's just
that that is how we're built I think so
I think that is super key I think
sweetness and femininity are
the the the ultimate things that stick
out to me really like you said you don't
want to be in a situation with somebody
where it's going to be competitive right
I mean I was in a I was in a situation
that was very brief because I didn't
allow it to continue with with a woman
who was incredibly competitive
um and and really tried to sort of
I don't know man I mean she was just off
on a different thing and it was like I
can't I can't live with this and I don't
want to live with this I don't want to
live in this situation this isn't what
how is this pleasurable right you know I
want to be with somebody who is who is
sweet who's feminine who's nurturing and
who you can and who who also makes an
effort to understand the male position
in all of this as well because I think a
lot of women don't or they and they
don't try to and I think it's important
for her to understand the male side of
things and somebody as well where you're
looking for that ride or die really
ultimately aren't you you know somebody
who you could be honest with and say
look this is me this is how this is
going to go
there may be times when you know I'm
gonna go and do something over here but
it I love you you are my queen you are
the old you know you are the the top of
the pile for me but you've got to accept
the realities of my nature and I think
uh a woman who can have that
conversation and not get you know overly
emotional and understand from the
masculine point of view why that
conversation has to happen I think that
is the the ultimate thing for me really
I agreed I think it's just so difficult
for us females like going back to what
you said when we we want to be in our
like we want a guy to completely just
take care of us and protect us and be
that hero you know every girl we've been
told all these fairy tales all these
stories when we're growing up we're fed
it from when we were kids like do you
know it is delicious oh my God we got
through to them
it's the guy saving the female all the
time so I think that's when it hurts so
much when you finally say oh my God okay
I can let go I'm finally in professional
energy I don't have to protect myself
anymore I can finally go and that's why
it hurts so much when you see the guy
that you think you can do that with and
then they go out and
exercise the options like you said
that's why it hurts so much and that's
when it goes back to the original
questions to where you stay or do you go
also I tell you this is that for you sex
in a lot of ways equals love
for a minute does not yeah you know and
I think that's what's painful you like
how could he possibly do that when I
don't want to do that at all truly so
most women that are truly in love with a
man don't want us they don't know
another man exists and I think you said
that earlier and it's absolutely true so
for you you can't comprehend just like
we can't comprehend your your position
how could he possibly
love me the way I love him and still do
that and and you're completely valid in
that feeling it's just trying to get
through to anyone like men don't feel
that way
they don't explicitly say because that's
I think without without a shadow of a
doubt and that's why and that's why I
made the point earlier how far men will
go down the totem pole to do it it
haunts men in a lot of ways I'm telling
you I think that is the question that I
would ask when you say to me what
question do you want to ask men that is
the question when that happens
is it is love or is it just complete
just blind I don't care about that I
don't care about that I promise you he
does not care about her okay
even more if he's like not safe being
open it he's like sneaking out the house
and come back in he's got his family he
knows how you act like that must be even
worse your grandfather I think was a
good example because he did that he had
he had that kind of other side of his
life but he treated his main woman with
so much respect that he didn't shame her
by making it open yep respect and I
respect her for that because I think at
some point another thing I didn't
mention it's about compromise I like
women who are naturally feminine who
naturally understand like listen I'm
slightly less successful than Justin
right slightly right I've got one or two
million less right so
not every man's gonna be a superhero and
everyone's gonna have their flaws and
being able willing to kind of meet them
halfway and talk about things is is such
a rare trait and the prettier women get
the less likely they want to do that the
more they want to see a man bend over
and slide in the DMS and do all these
things because they think I can do it
and they all get played because the guys
that will do that are doing it because
they're horny that's it yeah
though is there a conscience after in
what way after that happens after they
do that like is there a conscience
speaking Yeah Yeah if they're running
around lying to people yes absolutely
absolutely and that's why it's so
important you to me truly a high value
man will live in truth yeah and this
undermines the whole toxic masculinity
exercise because because what you always
talk about is that he's actually just
being honest and authentic this is this
is my nature honesty this is how I am
and what's toxic how can you how can
anyone say that's toxic right I'll put
it to you like this if I if I love
myself
I have to believe that so many but
somebody would love me just the way I am
in full truth yeah and and the fact of
the matter is most the time when a man
gets caught he has been caught in
deception
so not only is he a liar he's a coward
and how can you respect a coward yeah
yeah that is truth that's very true that
is true I agree okay
raise it hands who thinks that they
could accept cheating if the guy was
open about it definitely what do you
mean it's not just opening not not give
him a hard time about it not bring it up
just yeah this is what he does I don't
think any woman's actually capable of
that because I think there'll be spurts
of outbursts and pain you have you have
the library right don't be spurts about
birds and pains and that is one of the
most important parts for a man if that
happens you have a job to stop what the
[__] you're doing and be there and sit
in that pain with her and help make it
better
I'm not talking about a man that doesn't
actually love you like this man will
actually love you and that's been the
hardest thing for for people to
understand especially and that's one of
the things I hated the most when I was
going through the pain of like breaking
up with girls I had feelings for is
I was in love with these girls I would
have sat down with them and and been
there I wouldn't have cried but I'd have
held them
you understand what I'm saying it's like
you don't have to be a dick to a woman
just because you're doing that it's this
is really about getting down to the
brass tacks of how we're actually wired
so you don't even want to do it it's
just oh like I said I paid it I'd pay
for it to go away and so it's so
interesting because you said
um like you you may have married those
girls absolutely yeah and the thing is
they may have gotten what they wanted if
they could have accepted that and and
you know what I think about that truly
all the the women that are like okay
I can see the world for how it is
this sucks is gonna hurt but I believe
him he loves me he makes me feel this
way jokes on all the other women because
they're getting the [__] man and guess
what those [__] men if given the
opportunity in a heartbeat not only will
do it but lie about it
and to me I look at those two scenarios
who's really winning yeah who's really
winning one of them's getting truth and
real love and probably a much better
life the other one's getting lied to and
getting a scrub and a coward
and that's just that's just how it is so
who's a joke on really it and when
when you read all these books and you
hear all this stuff and you hear these
women kind of being super masculine with
the attitude around it they've probably
never met a man who could sit down with
them and be emotionally intelligent
enough to love them through it and
explain it in an articulate enough way
with enough conviction not hiding from
it that they could ever be able to
accept it
so to add to that one one misconception
a lot of modern women have is that your
value is in your ability to sexually
please a man so I think older women know
that it's about your ability to take
care of the homes your feminine energy
so they think a lot of people women feel
if he cheats on me then it means I'm
nothing to him and I have no values
throw me away no no I slept with you for
the first time years ago we've already
read that book now your value is that
you're the wife like you're the pillar
of this house you make the food you make
this a whole you're supportive you're
you're the love of my life in some ways
you're my piece yeah you need you need
to Pivot to that because all this like
feminist ideology low-key sells you the
idea that like it's about the sex sex
lost five minutes This Woman's gonna
give up a multi-millionaire happy life
all those connections that for five
because he bust a nut and someone else
and she's gonna give up all that because
she thinks that's that's all that
matters with us that's that's the
definition of relationship and it's not
you [__] up old school Queens will
tell you that you think you think a
queen would would divorce the king if
that's even possible because he has a
concubine nah because you're still the
[__] Queen that's why yeah yeah
it's true well but I feel like we've
been fed for so long that it's like if
you do that then you have no value then
you're like a horrible but when my shoes
they always paint it like the manner the
like the worst that is the worst thing
they could possibly do when it's like
well we're not perfect either yeah and
so it's like we expect all this stuff
from men we expect them to provide for
us we expect them to be masculine to
lead be good looking tall
um successful and it's like if he he
checks every single box and he cheats oh
you should throw a good thing away you
should throw away your whole family and
never be it's not like you're gonna
replace him yeah so you my response to
that is you're gonna leave me for a man
that you love less that'll cheat on you
anyway
it's true
because even you talk to like married
couples and they've been together for
long like I realize they always start
with oh there's ups and downs
and downs is like talking about them
situations where it's like yeah you
cheated I'm not happy about it but it's
like we move on because I love him I
don't believe in divorce look it's a
complete double standard because if a
woman cheats on a man he will leave her
in a second yeah because they know it's
emotional with women but it's like it's
like the trade-off thing right he's
going to go through all this hell and go
through all the stress and make sure
your world is a [__] Carpet Ride
and there's just one thing inside of him
that is in every side of every man but
you'll notice that he will not give
material assets to those other women
yeah but do you know what's funny I feel
like women really and truly like when
you're actually in the situation that
you're more upset with men that cheat
that that are not playing their role
like if a man is cheating and not paying
them you can actually effort that's the
deceitage
you're not gonna tell me you don't do
nothing my life sucks
like if the man is a father he's a like
your husband he like listens to
everything you say and then he cheats of
course you're gonna feel a type of way
but it's something you're going to work
through because it's like this is my
husband we're building a life together
so would you say that men making more
money in a way gives them the right to
cheat not just money it's like the whole
world they emotionally need to
because a lot of people just throw money
out and they stop it at money no I mean
love the woman yeah yeah I mean lover
that's why you can't just call anyone a
high value man until you know them
because high value man comes with so
many qualities not just money oh he's a
millionaire but he she get it like
that's character
to me in my opinion let me ask you a
question of of the guys I'm sure you see
millionaires right
would you say that
those guys have good strong connections
with their wives
no because obviously they come to me
because of what so like I said like the
wife after the third the first kid has
been like let herself go
down they come to me because because I
have the lingerie set because I'm
wearing makeup I'm wearing my fake
lashes I have my nails done and
obviously like in my case I don't even
look like a trans woman most of the time
and
even because like for example as and
I've been told by so many men
you're different from the other trans
women
and then I even went to my psychologist
one and a while and I asked him
why I have these men coming to me and
telling me like Regina you're different
than the other trans women
and like my psychologist told me oh it's
because like you've been you were born a
woman
okay um in fact like I came out to my
family when I was
four and my family has accepted that
since I was four
and I started transitioning like with my
head
than like a body and hormones and
everything
before I was a teenager like I've been
treated as Regina I'm from a family
since I was four
like the the guy came out so you came
out to your family at four and they
identified you as a woman yeah because
like for example I used to have
nightmares when I was when I was like
your mom and your dad both did my mom my
dad my grandmother and my grandfather
because in South America is not just
that the small nuclear of the family
like Mom and Dad it's everyone who
accepted this
um in kudos to them that's exactly what
they should have done
do you think the launch what I hear is I
do my lingerie I do the nails I do the
makeup
it probably in some way makes that man
feel like you went through some trouble
to try to please him in some way which
means that you were trying to like be
subservient in that way do you think
that's the thing that draws them in
because they tell you that what do you
think it is about you doing those things
that men like
uh
and I honestly I don't I don't really
know but like I mean I know that I'm
doing it at this then
so at the very beginning I was doing it
for myself
like because I wanted to be accepted
more like a woman right from the society
and then like I actually understood that
he's then liking it
so it's like
giving you know like because when you
give the treat to the but do you think
it's it's partly just down to this thing
that we've been talking about which is
that they want variety right I mean
they've been with these wives for
however long maybe it's you know it's
it's it's it's gone down the you know
it's gone down a little bit in terms of
the passion in the marriage and then
they're looking for some sort of variety
and that's where they come to you I'm
I'm curious do these men like
specifically seek out trans prostitutes
do these men specifically seek out trans
prostitutes
so basically like what can I say is
there's loads of confusion right now in
everyone's head because like I've got
guys coming to me that they're like oh I
don't know if I'm this
or I don't know if I'm there
they don't know if they're a man or a
woman like if they're gay or straight
and I'm like you know what
a gay man will never go with a trans
woman because a gay men will seek
another gay men
and
it's like as a lesbian woman will never
go with the
amen but but do they specifically like
seek out like so they do like for
example in my case they message me and
they're like oh how big are you and I'm
like um you know I don't know because um
it's not something that I do
and they're like oh so why are you doing
this job for and I'm like oh so why you
asking me questions for that they're not
already answered on my ad but when
you're advertising you're advertising as
as a trans woman yeah yeah
and they ask you how big you are in
regards to the member so you don't think
those men are homosexual yeah I do yeah
because and they're like trying to deny
the fact of their homosexuality
covering it by going with a trans woman
right because they're gonna be like okay
she's a woman like
on image right but and then I know what
we're doing in the bedroom but like as
well at the end of the day if trans
woman is a real trans woman
she's having a psychological problem
with her sex
like a
why if you are a smart person
why would you even go
and touch that psychological problem
more than
how it's not already because like as I
said if I'm not showing something on my
advertisement
why would you come and ask me about that
yeah okay because if it's not advertised
like like being an escort is being like
putting yourself in a shop
in the like in davitrine of the shop
and I'm showing you already by pictures
and videos of what I'm gonna offer I
obviously probably wrote as well a
presentation
that most of the people doesn't even
read
so you can even write like hello my name
is uh these and I want to do this but
I'm gonna do that because I wanna do it
they will never read it so I and you
don't have to answer this if it's
offensive at all but you said you
transitioned you started like
transitioning from four
yeah that sounds a little bit sad to me
because it's like how did you how did
you know what you
wanted at four you know because I and I
just say this because I was a bit of a
tomboy you know but because like they
let me chose what how I wanted to work
well so because for example
it was Monday morning and I had to go to
school obviously when it's back in
Venezuela I had to wear the uniform so
it was neutral
because in my school like the girls
wouldn't even wear skirts because it
wasn't Evangelistic okay let's go and
like everyone was wearing jeans yeah I
had a similar antipolar t-shirt because
they wanted like everyone to be the same
yeah but then like in on the daily
things they will let me choose what I
wanted to do and like any whatever I was
inclined for they will accept it because
they were like a
whoever she wants to be
I want we want a happy
to be who she wants to be and why we
will have to
like preclude someone to not be to
someone to not be someone that they
don't want to be so when did you start
like growing your hair out wearing
makeup how old were you I said so
basically because my families are really
so my family is their politicians and my
from my grandmother's side we comes from
the Irish family from Spain
I had to wait like all my cousins until
I became 13 to wear makeup presumably
Venezuela is quite traditional as well
though right I mean is it fairly
conservative sort of country
um yeah it's very Christian it's a kind
of similar to Brazil
and but it can it can be even worse
right because Brazil has its like a
Portuguese community and it's a
Portuguese colony
it's more on their own
yeah Brazil's like the only place in
South America that we don't we're not
Hispanic we're Latina but we're not
Hispanic we haven't seen views but it's
more like Western espresso then it's
still very sorry but still then it's
like very conservative yeah yeah the
whole of South America but Brazil was
mostly Western right yeah yeah I mean I
do imagine your parents or your family
must be somewhat liberal
[Music]
he's always been on the opposition
like opposition to the communism
oh he's not a communist
because like for example Venezuela it's
a it's a communist country now like
nothing comes out of Venezuela knowing
first and nothing goes in it's becoming
like even more and more every year like
um North Korea um
like even me like sometimes I can't even
talk to my family because they don't
have internet
oh wow
and then like sometimes and I as I said
my grandmother She's suffering of
dementia and my mom too
they both gone together at the same time
and I am the one like now trying to help
sometimes somehow like trying to speak
with a with a nurse and I'm like
sometimes I'm even having like a three
weeks where I know I don't know anything
about them and I'm like um
I always
say like
I always wait for a signal like from I
don't know from God or whatever because
anyway they always say like if you're
really close to your family you're gonna
feel when someone is gone
and I remember even when I felt my
grandfather when my grandfather died
like no one told me but I felt like
someone killed me
and that's how it what I can think of
her like a
of a man of a woman as well of um you
know of a high level of high standards
is when they teach you like a
that love goes no matter what
you just don't need money you just don't
need anything else
I'm really surprised your family was so
um accepting it sounds like they're
conservative
sir like
I think it's uh
yeah they wear but with me they always
had like that
um I don't know it's probably because I
was born premature and stuff so they
were like okay let's
keep her on a bubble but like not too
much and
and as well like they had examples of
other families where like uh I don't
know the kid was like turning against
their family
and uh plus as well by being a family
always constantly under the the lights
and stuff like that they didn't want
like even as well like you know like
having a granddaughter or grandson at 16
years old that hangs himself and end up
on the newspaper
[Music]
like if it's something that I would have
they wanted to accept you yeah and as
well like I I think it's something that
I will have to sit down with my
grandmother which is like on her 90s but
in her head she's 25. and she's telling
me how she's living her best life at 25
years old and I'm like all right
yeah do you feel like it's a fair
statement that
parents should have their child wait
until they hit puberty and adulthood
before having a surgery
let them play that out yeah like of
having a final surgery yeah I will I
will always suggest everyone no matter
what like wait until you can choose one
yourself as an adult and you've been
through puberty and you've been through
the feelings that you have sexually when
you go through pre-reader because I just
although your story is very beautiful I
would not want it to misrepresent that
it is child abuse to cut a child before
they even hit puberty or have the
ability to be an adult and make an adult
decision for example in my case I
haven't took any like any pill any block
here any okay any
until I was like until I was 13
which is when I chose
took it oh that's so young that's so
young which is where I choose whether I
wanted to take it or not and I was like
yeah I want it
but do you know do you know why I'm I
kind of like that I think not especially
now that you you know that you don't
want to go back but it's like me even
when I'm 21 now but even when I was like
17 I was such a tomboy like I've changed
so much like even now I feel like I'm
still trouble I feel like I'm getting
more and more feminine yeah but I think
it's because culture wise as well at the
same time like she said as well before
like um in South America you are like
undirected onto things but it seems to
me that surely it'll almost be the other
way around because in South America it
seems like it's more conservative
particularly because you're saying you
know you come from quite a conservative
family so it seems surprising that you
know you're relatively Young when you
started to do this I would have thought
it would be more like the other way
around they would have made you wait for
a bit longer yeah no but like I always
think like it comes as well like a
with the background of the family and
everything yeah like like I said like
they're quite International more or less
and as well like my grandmother's family
has a background on the aristocracy in
Spain that they were like all right we
shouldn't be judging older ones
it is surprising because it would have
been in the 90s if you'd have been four
you're 28 yeah yeah so it had been 95 96
you were born I was born in 95. yeah so
it's just a completely different world
they weren't aware in the same way so it
is a bit surprising
them I just believe and the reason I'm
bringing it up and I think the reason I
got where we got earlier is because I
kind of knew and
I'm sitting here and I knew
in
me and you were talking but they are
listening and your situation is so much
different if I'm being fair from theirs
and
I just think it's important
that number one that I acknowledge that
I think it's beautiful that your family
loved you but at the same time your
situation is going to be substantially
different than the young lady sitting on
the couch yeah that's why I said to her
as well like my situation is different
it's different as well yeah and that's
why I even like on my own side I can
tell that there were so many things
where I would agree with you so many
things where I will agree with you so
many things where I will agree with them
and not like
I was trying to be ultimate matching
partial I could but like when I feel
like someone is trying to impose in
themselves and I'm gonna say like I'm
trying because I could have like a
misjudged and like uh took it in another
way that should I have it's completely
fine I do have a genuine question for
you I didn't mean to cut you off but
when you said you quite enjoy the work
I don't think a man
any man if they were told hey you can
you can get paid to have sex all day
would would not do that deal that's a
pretty cool gig do you feel like you
have the sex drive
of a woman or do you think do you
have you ever felt you know that urge
I'm talking about you know I know what
you what you were talking about
I am pretty sure that my sexual life
eats
normal the drive yeah no even the drive
like in my way woman or a man in my in
my case it's a more psychological it's
not physical anymore at my point as well
in age and time where I've been taking
as well like the appeals and stuff
I see things in a different way with two
different sides yes
I can feel things in two different ways
yeah because at the end of the day even
though like
I am a woman and I feel like a woman and
I'm gonna be a woman and I am a woman no
matter what
I still have the possibility like to
have like a
a masculine and a feminine thought which
everyone actually could have that way
because
at the end of the day when we are in our
mother's belly we have no sex until a
certain point but anyone everyone comes
from a neutral thing
but can I have a question and this is in
no like because you said your story and
I find it so beautiful and that you even
have the strength to even say it here
but do you think it's like respectful to
say that you are a woman instead of like
trans women like do you like make a
point to say trans women or is it okay
for you to just say I don't like it like
I always try to specify I am a trans
woman yeah okay because I'm
transitioning I'm learning as well at
the same time like everyone it is
because everyone is transitioning in
life
so once you're fully transitioned like
we feel comfortable to just say to
someone I'm a woman and without the
trans yeah in that way yes
okay
but because like there's another at the
end of the day but you know you wouldn't
be an actual woman
what makes a woman like a menstruation
the YouTubers because there's so much
things that make you yeah there's women
there's women that they but they were
born without uterus because they had a
malformation we're looking at exceptions
not the rule so I would say generally
it's women that can have kids women that
have ovaries women that have or don't
have a penis yeah like any of those
things so it's just like what it would
never bother me like the only thing that
would get to me is that if if a woman
that would try to give a young woman
advice
you know you know what I'm saying
because I know that what's inside of me
even if I started calling myself a woman
is completely different than what might
be in a young lady well like and then
like my question is why have I been
invited
men and women are invited to the podcast
yeah and then like I don't know I feel
like I'm being told like you're not any
of them and we're here to give other
suggestions to young women no you are no
I'm not saying that you're not no I'm
not I'm not talking oh okay
I mean like you're not a woman you're a
trans woman I was responding because you
said that you were gonna say you're a
woman in the future and I said no you
wouldn't be
well like um that's uh and you you know
like uh I always say like you should
think about before you say those kind of
things because you never know like I
don't know how how would you feel if
then tomorrow someone is calling you
like my manager he's calling you and
tells you you know Regina has hanged
herself because she didn't like the
words you used then I would say Regina
was weak probably she probably was weak
people call me really mean things on the
internet me too yeah I know like and I
know it for sure in person I've been
attacked on this oh yeah even me every
day yeah so I I please don't do that but
I don't think you should kill yourself
because someone called you yeah but
that's why I'm still alive what that's
why I'm still alive because I haven't
hugged myself because someone hasn't
called me you're not a woman right but I
just think I'm just not a liar
like I just I'm not gonna lie so it's
like when you say something that's not
true I'm not going to tell you it's true
yeah but that's because that's your
opinion as well and everyone is a
scientific fact I don't even think it's
just that as well like I think because
your story is so commendable and
everything and you're going through the
transition you should feel proud to say
I'm a trans woman I was watching this
video of this trans lady the other days
it was from like the 80s and she said um
Zach I'm proud to say my friends don't I
just don't know if I can say that and
I'm just trying to be honest I just
don't know if I can say that giving
drugs to someone at 13 is commendable
yeah you know I'm glad it like worked
out for you you seem happy but I just
think like if I would say that's a
connection but that's your feet
yeah that's my story because like now
because if you are if you do you know
other trans women or other trans people
because now you have to you have to wait
until you're 18 or even 21 25 26. in my
case it's because I come from another
country maybe rules might it might be
different than and I'm glad I'm glad it
worked out but to me it's still sad like
like honestly I was getting sad yeah but
like that because that's 13 that's okay
yeah but like for me and to me then to
me can be sad like yours the story of
your life because you've been precluded
onto something else
like everyone can everyone has their
story and their rights to write their
story and to tell their story so like
and you can tell it like I'm not telling
you don't tell it I'm just we're we're
talking about it yeah no and as well
like I'm like I said you have your
opinion it's good for you to have an
opinion I have another one
yeah I just I just can't imagine like 13
is just so like that's so young to me
because I think of myself when I was 13
I dressed like a freaking man and like I
said because it's because it's a
different culture it's a different
culture I think it's more than just
dressing like obviously I don't know
personally but I think obviously it's
chemicals and what's the thoughts and of
going on in your brain so I don't think
you can relate it to like your own
personal situation because that that
stuff's not okay I could because you
know honestly
if I did have a thought like that and
Society encouraged it or my parents
encourage it who knows maybe I'd be down
the same path I don't know but it's like
are you dressing like a tomboy did you
have thoughts of okay maybe this is
something actually that I need to dig
deeper in and actually think about well
because my parents would never let me no
but it's not about you yeah
reason for you in that case my parents
they will never choose for me yeah my
parents because because my parents they
say you have a right to speak and you
have your right to think I think I think
the difference is though I I think it's
good that my parents chose for me in a
lot of situations because when you're
young you can make choices that affect
the rest of your life I'll give you an
example
um not not so much as gender
transitioning but tattoos like I'm
really glad I don't have any tattoos but
when I was younger I wanted I wanted to
get them to piss my mom off I'm not
saying that's a good thing to do but but
they said no you can't ever do that so
like I don't know just drugs you know
like I should I have to say though like
you know
I I think I I'm on this debate I'm more
side with a lot of women who feel like
the the experience of Womanhood is two
two personal spiritual Divine and they
you know sometimes they reject the idea
of you know a trans woman Etc and um I
don't I think I form on that side but I
I have a massive amount of respect for
you for your personal experience I can't
imagine what it's like to feel like you
you're supposed to be in another body
that must be crazy just hearing you is
like you know me trying to empathize is
like kind of wild because I'm thinking
that that is wild imagine if you felt
like that and if I'm honest I will never
put myself on the same like level of a
woman who was born woman and I will
never try to do that because there are
two different stories two different
lives two different kind of environments
I will never go through what a woman
goes through as as the same way a woman
will never go through
to what I'm going through definitely
okay I'm glad I'm glad that that's
acknowledged right I have a lot of
respect for for people like you and like
your personal experience 100
um and personal identity um but yeah
agreed okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
really quick and then we're going to
close out the show um so when we close
out the show we're gonna do final
thoughts so if there's anything you want
to speak your piece on anyone you want
to tell off yeah or you know think
whatever
um okay guys make sure you like the
video um the like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams so make sure you like I
think we're at a thousand one what are
we 1200 likes
yeah one one two so let's try to get to
one five before we end the stream
um as you're logging off make sure you
like the video on your way out and also
subscribe to the channel um also guys
make sure you subscribe to one of our
two clips channels Pearl daily and just
pearly Clips um okay
guys Regina is a girl um he argues just
like one close your eyes and listen to
him nothing sounds different than a girl
working at McDonald's or any of these
ladies on the panel all women think the
same you can feel however you want but
prostate breast cancer is a real thing I
pray for you Erica just be ladylike and
you'll get a good man
um you have the equipment now fix the
attitude the clue Channel Pearl you need
an I feel like jar in the studio 93 top
I dare these women to have an honest
conversation with their parents
separately about their dating life
before being together it'll shock them
seeing their moms their mom basic as
they are and dad is a winner Sean
everybody judges not all put into words
lifestyle is not your future when you
are 40 hit the wall lifestyle will be on
the list listen or suffer facts do not
care about your feelings Griffo as Pearl
still single she is so beautiful and
classy God bless her and her supporters
Edgar that's why you do Brazil if it's a
noble
um with your parents um blood velvet
um seven the Commandment disagree with
you Bible you shall not commit adultery
but I say to you that everyone who looks
like a woman with lustful intent already
has already committed adultery within
her heart exploring fam life um
shout out to the real world Jay Waller
um crazy world crazy times um Candy
Store women are given a free passing in
the candy store at their Prime and pick
the candy high value men but they taste
all the candy men have to work like hell
to enter the store and if they pick
wrong young raw they pick young women or
taste more candy misogynist
um why NT silk sorry guys some of these
usernames Hebrews 13 4 let marriage be
held in honor among all and let marriage
be as on oh shoot sorry
sorry I exited out
um
okay let marriage be held in honor among
all and let marriages and let the
marriage bed be unified for God will
judge the sexual immoral sexually
immoral and adulterous
um Exploring Life fam shout out to the
real world Jay Waller um a brand F1
shout out to blessing I'm straight up
Pearl you're a catch to be honest to
Waller even losers cheat and it's for
them to Pearl 8 000 years ago for real
everyone raised communities children in
communities um she'll hear us Pearl
please look up
bring on the screen um red pill animated
it's animated red pill easier to digest
PS one's the sound board coming I don't
know some super chats
um if there's a channel you want me to
react to send it to me on Instagram just
pearly things one um that's the best way
to send me stuff for shows Sean and G
keep on fighting Pearl Abram F1 uh Pearl
is being smart well red oh I wrote this
one already
um and then let me refresh it one more
time before we end the show also guys
make sure you go subscribe to wife
school I know I've been promising the
two wife School episodes um I did what I
would cook for my husband in a day and I
learned how to knead bread
um and and
um yeah I know it's been slow and I've
been promising that but we're getting a
new editor this week so it's coming I
swear
um Sean NG why not why not just call
yourself a trans woman not a woman and
empower the trans woman in itself your
life story is understandable but
objectively you know 13 as a child
okay
um any final thoughts
um starting here there and then second
row
um the first thing that comes to my mind
is just I think we live in a world where
we feel like
um we all need to be on the same page
but something that Alex said earlier
about compromising makes me think that
I I think being able to be reasonable is
the key you know to listen to other
people you don't have to understand each
other because I'm a woman you're a man
we don't we're not going to understand
each other maybe not but can we can we
talk can we communicate and can we be
reasonable I think that's kind of what
we need to start asking ourselves
and that's that's my final thought
agreed I'll take off that just just be
happy man just live your life take each
day as it comes you never know when
you're going to get swiped off the Earth
you just don't know what's going to
happen in your day so just love every
one of them the most amount you can and
God bless and good night yeah
yeah me too I agree with her like
nothing is really settled to like one
specific
everything's what you make here I don't
really have
a change of mind in terms of like the
adultery part
I agree with most of everything that was
said
I'd say fine truth even if it hurts yeah
once you go through it it you'll find
that living without the weight of
disingenuousness or lies and allowing
yourself to be happy inside the real
truth and the real reality of the world
is probably your best bet
and tell them your YouTube channel Jay
Waller and Instagram is Justin
winwaller7
yeah I would agree with that I think
that you've got to try to look at the
world with a Clear Vision and try to
accept Life On Life's terms and reality
on reality's terms and
you know as and try to strip away the
Pretty Lies as much as possible because
the reality is you know there is a
market out there we're all part of the
market men and women you know we're all
being judged all the time um in terms of
what we bring to the table whether we
like it or not and you've just got to
deal with that and it's fine I think
it's absolutely commendable for people
to have their own aspirations for their
relationship life the things that they
want the things they don't want but
you've also got to look at that in the
context of that Marketplace and think
okay so realistically if I'm going for
that top 20 guy am I gonna get you know
these things on my checklist and just
you know take it like that uh you can
follow me on YouTube at real Troy
Francis and also Instagram and the other
socials at real Troy Francis
fun and
I don't know
final thoughts there's love anyway like
no matter what you're gonna be judged
whatever you're gonna do
and if you feel fine and happy when you
do it just do it
okay
um my final thoughts would be
um
I'm still gonna go into a relationship
with the expectations of not getting
cheated on but if he plays that role
right
back
but the expectation is going to be there
and especially like what you said like
um he doesn't want to do it and if he's
actually going to love me the way I want
to be loved because I could settle for
someone and ain't gonna love me the way
I want to be loved and you know we're
just sitting there broke and just loyal
and yeah like I just yeah yeah so yeah
that's my final thoughts
my final thoughts will be I would
suggest young ladies now more than ever
find a mental find a wise woman who has
achieved lasting happiness and a strong
stable relationship and learn from them
back in the day women were trained early
to be wives you were you know you're
doing all this housework you were
trained in courtesy and Etc you guys
don't have that you got cardi B now so
I don't care you better figure out but I
will say find those women and learn from
as much as I can learn so much from
older men like Justin who's accomplished
all these things I think women need to
take that on like being a housewife or
being being a woman or the divine
feminine is not easy it's just as
difficult as being a man it's just a
different kind of struggle and don't
underestimate that it is not a one I
feel like it Journey kind of thing it is
a discipline relationships and long-term
success with anyone and anything takes
discipline
that's what I'll say
okay guys thank you for coming this was
a really fun panel tonight I know you
know sometimes things got heated but I
really did enjoy everyone on the panel
so
um
and shout out to Justin for coming all
the way from Louisiana you know to
London shout out
um okay guys
um so after the show I have a reaction
video that's premiering
um I think I reacted to like kids on the
street or something like giving their
answers about love so it's kind of funny
so
um watch that next also guys um sneakos
here tomorrow so make sure you tune in
um we're gonna try to start by 8 30
might be nine um tomorrow for the live
um go follow my Instagram if you have
any videos you want me to react to or
topics you want me to cover um send them
to me on Instagram just pearly things
one also subscribe to wife school and
also guys we're going to start doing
meetups I'm going to the US next month
so I'm probably gonna do meetups in
different cities if you want to be a
part of those sign up for our email list
um that should be in the description
like the video on your way out and I'll